going
live shared
boom all right boys and girls you know
what to
do we are here but we're not here until
you can hear what we are here to say so
let us know if you can hear us if we're
coming through loud and clear first and
foremost I want to say a big old thank
you to you guys for being here we
already got a Super Chat coming in that
is very much appreciated thank all of
you guys seriously it's Friday today
it's a day earlier than we normally do
these we got some news to talk about
some fresh trailers everything's going
according to Planet Marvel you guys are
a test audience see how Friday streams
do so oh look out they can hear they can
hear Coy is my guy says Hellcat big rude
88 great
L going on in there
absolutely thank you for being here with
me today I've been looking forward to
streaming with you it has it's been
months it has been many months it feels
like many a moon and uh we are the two
most organized efficient guys on this
channel be very efficient and smooth
Chop Chop man that's how I love to live
my life uh so we are on a bit of a time
crunch got a busy schedule today uh you
know as you can see I am in uh the seat
right here I'm going to be doing stuff
that Greg normally does before we begin
quick Round of Applause for Greg uh I
would love again to get all three of us
on a stream but he is out he is tackling
tasks and taking meetings and whatnot so
uh you know he he is nosing on the
grindstone so we are here to talk about
the news this week we got plenty of
stuff to dive into um and yeah but just
before we do that once again seriously
thank you guys for being here and and
thank you as well to anybody who
contributes no matter how big or small
it really really helps out a lot
especially with these live streams uh
you know playback can be a little bit
tricky um and your guys support helps to
boost these in the algorithm get more
eyeballs on them and especially you know
we try to keep these as familyfriendly
as we can but sometimes it's hard
sometimes they do get limited or
restricted in ways um so yeah your guys
support and your interactions just in
general uh make all the difference so
really really appreciate you guys uh
appreciate you guys uh if you leave a
super chat or a streamlabs uh there's a
pinned link for the streamlabs uh you
know YouTube doesn't take a cut of that
but really anything and everything is
appreciated and if you contribute your
contribution your question your comment
will be read it will be read guaranteed
so uh we got a lot to get to as we've
already got a few uh streaming in so uh
I think that's all the Housekeeping did
you said on the notes absolutely uh
before uh before the Monumental moment
in every live stream where koi takes
over I mean it's in the text it's right
there but it's also I'm not I'm going to
behave today I'm going to see how well
let's see how how nice I can be to
strangers I like it you know after
especially after the very calm live
stream you guys had talking about the
Marvels which everyone agrees upon oh
100% they got Twitter koi last week oh
Twitter Coy Twitter I think live Coy and
Twitter Koy are very similar we got
instaco today he's gonna be civil
adjacent he's got to be right there
PG-13 rage yeah I like oh that's good I
like it let's let's let's see who's in
the chat really quick we got Olivia
Hamlin what's up Kevin Shepard nerdy ly
templo asking who would be uh who hasn't
been thought of would be a great Reed
Richards Joseph Gord levit oh hey
haven't heard that name mentioned he'd
be great he's got that intelligence he's
got that movie star quality he's got
that caring of family he's a family man
he's got a little bit of that pacity in
a good way I think Joe has that like I
can use polyic words eloquently I uh I'm
g go Joe Joe Gordon L I love it I love
it co I'm going James Remar for uh uh Mr
fantastic I think he bring it uh and
just at his current age I think is
appropriate keep everybody at the other
rumored casting you know Elizabeth diii
or whoever is supposed to be or is it
the other one from Mission impossible
mission impossible but I was letting you
have it I was let it you're like hey
that's I get her mixed up with Elizabeth
dicki all the time Vanessa Kirby Vanessa
Kirby there you go we got bra momento we
got Jordan style Jamie Smith MJR Tom
music Aisha Kenya in the chat
we got uh oh who else who else Jazzy man
we got so many lovely and beautiful
faces uh all right well hey I I you know
again I'm I'm going to do my best to to
moderate and I feel like now's the good
as any time to jump into our first topic
I feel like you know one of the main I
don't know which do you think is is
bigger the F4 or or or the Kang well the
Kang is a little bit more confirmed sure
okay we can start there then yeah let's
go there because it is is tangible sure
uh let's uh let's just talk about the
fact that we have probably not getting
King the movie K Dynasty I feel like
that's I mean you lose a right or you
lose a director it's just a weird way to
go about canceling a movie in Parts yeah
yeah who was that that was Jeff lovess
yeah Jeff less made an announcement last
week and Dustin Daniel keton has uh
exited as well but he's not leaving the
Marvel Universe because he's focusing in
shuni 2 he's also involved with
Wonderman which got announced this week
I don't know if you heard as a Marvel
search light okay so Wonderman is still
a go
res explain to the people so Marvel
search light is going to be a focus on
individual characters that are going to
be within the MCU but not a focal point
so it's not saying they're out of
continuity necessarily it could be but
like for example if they made werewolf
by night now they'd probably call it a
Marvel search light and then later on
you might get to see Wolf by Knight in
another movie but it's like you don't
have to see this to go into uh you know
the next Avengers film it's not like
mandatory viewing so it allows you to be
a little bit more flexible with what you
must watch so Marvel search light is
kind of like an annual or a you know
oneoff a one shot a u mini series and
comic terminology it's going to be like
a little isolated baby boy um so search
light is going to be wonder man it's
going to be echko it's going to be a few
other things uh oh it's Spotlight I was
I you know I watched I watched a Fox
Search light movie last night and I was
thinking about how much I missed Fox
Search light as kind of a similar thing
where it's like Fox but like the more
Indie contained thing so now in my head
they're the same I'm so sorry
for repeating Spotlight 100 times no no
joke I was literally about to ask you if
this was like through Fox Search light
as like a means of making more
independent in my brain I made the one
Spotlight apologies um but I do think
Spotlight is smart and uh I I'm excited
about Wonderman so uh Destin is not no
longer in the Marvel business he still
very much is but I don't feel like Kang
Dynasty is happening gotcha okay okay I
mean that'll that'll be a bummer but
obviously that's giving way to something
that people are very much excited about
and I mean before we jump on to the uh
the uh the the elephant in the
Doom what do you guys think just are you
are you dismayed by this I know that the
Kang storyline thus far and you know the
overarching quality of it has not
amounted to as much as they promised so
I mean would you guys be uh bummed or
upset to lose the prospect of you know
this Kang Centric you know Trio of faith
is really it seemed like it was going to
you know carry through to or at least
heavily slingshot into the secret Wars
and all that stuff um so yeah I mean you
know would you Greg is sleeping finally
hopefully uh GRE a bevy of meetings the
last time Greg actually slept on record
was somewhere in like March of 2020
right when right when the world shut
down you know like that's when he took a
nap that was a full sleep though 2021 I
heard he got a nap in
uh he he does rest Rip Van Winkle style
but only for like a day Rip Van Alba Rip
Van Greg I tried yeah there you go
that's better than mine yours is better
than mine coy as is of known to be the
case and so yeah this is potentially uh
going to lead us into a Switcheroo where
we get uh Dr Doom
in it was always going to be doom and
that's what I think is going to be
tricky is now you don't have I I think
it was pretty obviously not necessarily
to every audience but to the comic
audience that secret Wars is very
doombased so I I thought the plan from
the jump was going to be Kang Dynasty is
a Kang Centric film much like Infinity
War but instead of it being like Oh my
God a onew punch of Kang folling into
Secret Wars it was going to be him Doom
taking out Kang to show how op he is so
basically we get yeah imagine seven
movies of this character and you're like
he's taking out everyone and then Doom's
like what up and that shows Doom
dominance doomin if you will but now
without that dominance how are they
going to show how powerful Doom is cuz
basically now you got to introduce Doom
without that Kang um level up that
alleyoop that you know onew punch that
that Brady de Moss the Unstoppable toss
um how you going to do that in one movie
because basically now I imagine you can
introduce him in cap 4 as a geopolitical
Intrigue like we had heard they were
with wak forever um I can imagine they
can introduce him obviously in Fantastic
4 but you've only got so much time
before Secret Wars if you don't do Kang
Invasion if they do make super if they
do make secret Wars a part one part two
tricky well and and two then my question
becomes you know is that Captain America
for retooling really because of all
these reportedly terrible test
screenings or is it because they need to
you know reconfigure this phase I think
it's a it's a combination of I mean I
don't know how much of the rumors of of
screenings are true um but I do think
six months is a new movie um sure end
game endgame shoot schedule was six
months
the re- shoots are longer than endgame
schedule okay that's a new move yeah and
I mean I'm fascinated to see what what
this is going to amount to in terms of a
business thing just because these it
seems like Marvel projects the more
modular they become the more able to
re-shoot and retool the more expensive
kind of exponentially the more the
budgets balloon on these things and
especially in like a postm Marvel's
world where a lot is being made of how
costly uh by compar each minute of that
movie was and just the fact that that
movie seemed like something that and I I
don't know the full production history
but something that may have been
reworked retooled as well to some extent
uh I I'm I'm curious to see how this
affects their film making approach as
well as their storytelling approach
because two I mean they this to me says
that like they're going to have to be a
lot more careful in the future about
what they announce and how much planning
they give us in advance because they I
mean they debuted three phases you know
I remember that ComicCon presentation
and granted that stuff is fleeting and
ultimately pretty ephemeral just because
you know it's just news and the News
cycle is always changing and updating
but at the same time I feel like we are
getting to this point
where it might behoove them not to plan
out loud so far ahead because you never
know what's going to happen need well it
sounds like they got pressured into that
like it sounds like Kevin feige was told
he had to announce Fantastic 4 to the
point where got to learn well that d23
conversation where it's like yes we have
Fantastic 4 no we're not talking about
it look the directors in the audience
like that felt really like well this is
weird like he felt like mad they had to
say it and I'm like oh and now we're
finding out it was that awkward so I I
don't think they should announce
anything more than a year ahead and I
don't think they should announce all
these release dates and things that are
are obviously having to shift but I
would rather them remake cap four than
release a bad cap 4 I'd rather them
retool in pre-production and production
than in post-production and and have
haphazard films because they can't
afford the bad word of mouth forever you
know they can't sure they
can't the Marvels is the most profitable
movie of the year clearly that's not
true Marvel's so dead Marvel's back
Marvel's so dead Marvel's back I am so
tick to back in the grave they're back
in the grave so we'll see Aisha Kenya
says they need to bring in Doom as soon
as possible but will it make sense koi
it he needs uh time um he got you got to
make it count it's got to be impactful
it's got to
be like important and you don't like
Thanos took time to feel that weight and
you really need to
H cap four is the soonest they could do
it and that would be like geopolitical
and I think that'd be smart if they
mentioned lat varia and then they had a
post credit scene but that's the
quickest you could do it yeah I'm I'm
very very very very curious and
fascinated to see how this is going to
go and obviously we also had the recent
news that they are pushing pretty much
everything that's not Deadpool 3 into
2025 yeah so that any it's weird delays
can often Inspire uh you know uh
weariness but for me Marvel delaying is
usually like a sign of like oh good
they're going to take a little more time
and maybe think this through um so yeah
like this seems like a very uh this is
going to be interesting to watch
basically uh to see how they adjust and
yeah I mean we've got certainly time
time um but not K the Conqueror of time
yeah and and does necessarily maybe I'm
I'm most curious to see how they're
going to handle this transition because
enough people have been paying attention
that you know the die hards will know
and at least just be looking out for how
smooth the transition is but a lot of
people out there are just going to be
like wait a minute I thought we had this
K guy what what are we doing discarding
this but the way Loki ended you know and
and the way they chose to have Ant-Man
end kind of in ways doesn't need to if
if that's you could just be done with
Kang for right now and have him come
back way down the line as somebody else
or something yeah yeah um and so hey
with all this fantastic far talk uh
that's a pretty nice segue into our all
but almost not quite confirmed bit of
casting that has taken people much by
surprise uh not I think the name anyone
was expecting necessarily uh Koy that's
who you are Kus who's going to be Mr
Fant seem the people are saying eyeing
hearing rumoring possibly Pedro Pascal
oh uh the the world's daddy and you know
the zatty of us all he's a
multi-universal zatty if there's a kid
in Peril he's there reluctantly um you
know I don't I don't know I I love Pedro
Pascal but I I just don't I feel like
he's too approachable in a weird way um
like there's something about him that
feels like he's Rough and Tumble and
he's got like this gruffness but it's
not in the way that the gruffness would
be an arrogance I think Pedro pcal is
too cool like he's too he's like got a
likability about it they're going to put
glasses on and then he's a nerd and then
he's a nerd Coy he's going to be so
clumsy I just don't see the arrogance uh
in that way coming out of Pedro pcell
like he's a guy that like you know
you're running Oscar Isaac on the seat
Maxwell
Lord favorite role the biggest villain
in the DC EU I just I don't know like I
I like the F I don't necessarily love
this casting but I do trust in if it is
true Sarah Haley Finn has not miscast in
my opinion any very important role and
this is such an important role like it's
got to work with the whole family it's
got to work with other Avengers it's got
to work with the Illuminati like this is
such an important role and to to for my
money she hasn't miscast any one of that
importance sure like she's so good at
seeing 10 years ahead she's so good at
like mapping things out uh I'd love to
have you know Pedro Pascal in the MCU I
just don't I don't see him as as as read
for me okay I mean it's one of those
things where I heard it and to uh you
know was sort of like oh I wasn't this
last person I was expecting and I did
hear a quote that I'm sure is going to
you know make the internet so happy uh
which I don't know if it's verified but
somebody said said that like Kevin fogy
remarked like you know this is a very
white fantastic for we should mix it up
maybe at least a little bit um and so I
don't know maybe that has something to
do with it but I do like the idea of
having a casting choice for a character
as iconic as this that isn't likely
because looking back I feel like some of
the most memorable the most impactful
the most iconic comic book movie
performances have been those choices
where everyone's like what why you know
like why would you choose this person or
what did what have they done in the past
that would suggest they should do this
and I won't be upset until I see it and
and then I don't feel connected like I'm
I'm in Blind Faith to the casting
director's skill so like I'm not saying
it's bad I'm saying like that's not who
I would see personally but that's I'm
not a casting director yeah yeah and it
makes me wonder too how they do their
casting because I'm sure Pedro Pascal
has not had to audition for anything in
a long time but it seems like it is
Pedro he's not some Pedro's white he's
not like all white at least right like
Pascal I don't know what race uh is he
doing a Carlos menia
I don't know um and some people say they
like Pedro more for Doom could you see
that he doesn't have the arrogance for
either to me like he both are like the
point of their rivalry is pomposity
they're both such like I'm the smartest
and like neither of them to me Pedro
pescal he seems like a guy I want to
have a beer with like Pedro pescal is
like I'd want to run into Pedro pescal I
wouldn't want to run into Doom ever and
I wouldn't want to be stuck in a room
with Reed like I and that's that's
what's funny is like I enjoy I've had a
few interactions with Joseph and Le that
are all very positive he's not someone I
would want uh that I'm saying I wouldn't
want to be stuck in a room with but he
can play that like he's got uh like he
can play that equalizer level where he
can bring that out of him but I don't
I've yet to see a performance and I'm
not saying he's not capable I just
haven't seen a performance where I'm
like I don't want to be around that guy
all right all right I absolutely know
what you mean he is a very appealing
performer even he's Gruff that's why he
makes such a good reluctant Daddy
because you want to be with him you want
his approval even when he is being Gruff
but that to me is a fun Prospect because
I'm excited to see him unlock that side
of his his you know repertoire as an
actor and it makes me curious quick
shouts out to Bucky Barnes in the chat
just for moderating holding it down
really appreciate you um it it makes me
curious how they go about this because I
feel like you know marvel is at current
moment you know at the Pinnacle of you
know the current film landscape so even
people who don't audition I imagine
would have to test and read well at
least a chemistry read do something like
that so so part of me is like maybe you
know Sarah Hy Fin and whoever else have
seen him do some kind of read uh that
they like or or something like that but
yeah you know put it to you guys are you
looking forward to Daddy p
as Reed it's the best rhyme I could do
in a short amount of time
um and then yeah somebody asked in the
chat uh the Kang uh dispersal has not
been like 100% confirmed by Marvel but
it certainly appears that dynasty movie
falling apart does not bode well yeah so
either those people are just tired of I
guess you know with all this being hung
up in Jonathan Major's legal troubles
maybe they're just tired of being at a
standstill I'm sure on those particular
projects and they want to go work on
something that's actually going to move
but at the same time it does seem like a
significant possibility yeah more and
more it seems significant and I we don't
know anything more than you guys do ab
yeah that's what we've heard unless you
do scoopers in the chat sound off Paul
Dixon thinks he will be fantastic which
I think is a a good bit of optimism uh
hey someone wants to know what Doom's
powers are really quick keep it keep it
simple for the idiots like me he is the
most intelligent man in his mind on the
planet but he's got that intelligence in
a mix of Science and Magic uh his mom
was uh basically a witch and he learned
through his you know lineage and also
through years and years of study the
combination of of magic and science and
he can make most anything uh he's a
dictator ruler of lataria that rules the
Iron Fist he has technological Savvy the
likes of which uh you know he can make
doombots not quite on caliber with Iron
Man but pretty damn close so imagine
someone that is so smart they are both
Iron Man and Doctor Strange but they
have the arrogance to think they're the
best thing on the planet and aren't
worried about the cost of life so it's
the arrogance of Iron Man without any
sort of reluctance and the power of
Doctor Strange without any sort of like
worrying about the cost so it's the a
fearful power and and an absolute belief
in self like imagine uh you know imagine
if Kanye West decided to uh learn a
violent skill and he believed in himself
as much as Kanye West does it'd be
pretty dangerous I Kanye should play
that's confirmed Dr Doom y you heard it
here first but that that kind of like
blind arrogance like where you're like
nothing the reality of the world doesn't
matter my reality is what matters new
math and uh it's new math uh Johnny
shears uh it has not been confirmed that
he has cast as Mr Fantastic though uh it
has been heavily rumored and that rumor
has been adopted and propag and and
spread by uh various I guess more
reputable outlets and so at least right
now it seems like perhaps a little bit
more than a rumor and per maybe even a
likelihood basically also uh notorious
sloth uh just brought up and I just saw
this earlier Stephen Yun uh for Century
can you give us like a brief 30 to 45
seconds on who centy is and if you like
Steph uh imagine if centy imagine if
Superman was the stereotypical not the
actual diagnosed version I'm not a
doctor but the stereotypical movie
version out I had Superman until I'm not
a PhD but uh imagine if you were like in
the movie s schizophrenic or bipolar or
any of those uh mental health verion
yeah the EDG super that you're like man
I don't have any guilt because I'm over
here as this lady um Kanye is doomed no
one man should have all that yeah
actually you know what what's a king to
a god what's a god to a nonbeliever is
kind of Doom's whole OS that song Watch
the Throne is Dr Doom if you want to
know who Dr Doom is play Watch the
Throne um but uh
basically he's like a a a mix of dark
and light his Superman side is Sentry
his dark side is like all powerful all
consuming Darkness but he can't control
it and he's mentally unwell um and
Steven y i i don't um know a lot of his
work I never watched The Walking Dead uh
I love him as Invincible but um that
doesn't really help with my knowledge of
his Sentry I just I didn't get in I
don't like zombie stuff I'm sorry I like
zombie Landy I do too and that's and I
like the I like comedies sure but that
is isn't going to help me with Walking
Dead um yeah sorry it's just my buddy
Ross is on do you like Marvel Zombies
cool I
I but uh yeah so Steph young I have no
reason to think he won't be great but
that's all I know groovy me too uh guys
we're going to hop into the Super chats
and streamlabs in a moment you guys have
been so patient and we've already got a
bunch of contributions so we really got
to get this let's do it roote on the
show uh real quick uh last little bit of
new stuff uh uh guys in the chat let's
pit these against each other let's let's
make more competition where there
doesn't need to be any uh what if season
2 trailer Madame web trailer which one
did you like more which one you looking
more forward to Coy what did you prefer
I mean I I enjoyed what if season one
but I haven't rewatched it I was pretty
casual about it I I wish it had impacted
anything ever like it was supposed to um
but like it was fun I Madam I love the
20 movies man like I'm I'm uh that's
when I really started watching movies
with a different eye so if anything's
going to mirror Final Destination if
anything's going to mirror the 2000s
when I was going to Blockbuster like
daily uh I'm a Leen I'm a Leen Madam web
like I I it's characters I never thought
I'd see on screen I never thought I'd
see Maddie on scre they were there in
the Amazon with my mom when she was
researching spiders that's where they
were and now that they're out in the
world in American Cinemas um I love
sorry to interrupt you on your own
though man I so adore that in no time
flat that has become a meme I've seen so
many uses and repurposing of that quote
in the last 24 hours in very fun ways I
so excited yeah I I'm I'm so stoked for
Madam web man I'm I'm like so in I I
love the 2000s I'm I'm
stoked oh dramatic pause that was for
you oh was it for me okay was that I was
like
for to be a moment of credence for the
uh theum and the fact that you know this
is the hill you're going to die on I am
man you'll see me rallying for these
Sony movies of yes uh and I and I'm and
I'm with you we got I mean we were
getting some love for uh what if in the
chat uh I hate zombie movies make a good
Blade movies says chaos 9999 I think
they are uh are you chaos 999 that's not
a name I hear read off at the end of YMS
videos all the time is it if not thanks
for also being here um uh final thing I
think before we hop I yeah I watched the
what if season 2 trailer it looked like
fun to me it looked like what if you
know whereas Madam web at least has that
like kookiness uh that you know there's
going to be way more curveballs even I
mean what if is is meant to be curve B
but I still feel like there's going to
be way more Insanity in Madam web and I
think that's what's calling it to me it
feels so different like I was I think I
think I said it on capes and cowls I
need Variety in my pizza just like I
need variety of my potatoes and
sometimes I want to go to Pizza Hut and
have a nice filling crusty Pizza that's
going to be fun sometimes I want like a
nice Gourmet Pizza that's going to be my
Logan that's going to be my AME
sometimes I want something comfy at home
while I watch something and that's Douro
and that's my Madam web it's not
delivery it's Douro and I'm very happy
when I'm in that mood I don't want
always Pizza Hut I don't want always uh
you know fancy prin Street sometimes I
want Douro and I'm glad they're giving
me that uniqueness it's not pizza it's
it's the Sony Pictures Universe of
Marvel character and I'm excited for uh
okay we're going to do a quick rapid
fire right here before we hop into the
chat just real quick the rest of the
Fantastic forecasting what do you think
Vanessa Kirby uh Su storm uh I think
it's great she's very very captivating
on screen and she speaks with such like
eloquence and she'd have to because in a
lot of ways she's smarter than Reed in
the the street sense like she can she
can keep up with Reed with just the
highbrow intellectual but she's smarter
about like dealing with the world she
has more Street smarts and she's smart
enough to keep up with the smartest man
on earth so like I think you need to be
able to speak with an incredible like
eloquence and seem like you can
understand quantum physics casually and
also like navigate it for she's kind of
our eyeline so I think Vanessa Kirby's
fantastic and she's such a boss when she
shows up on screen um even Moss backra
as the best casting like that is uh I
I've been saying col Hol Mallen Le for
years um sure he's like my thing and
he's the first name he's in my James
rear fantastic yeah that Fantastic Four
from the 80s Susan sandon Sue storm and
then uh and then uh just got to get
Johnny storm in there now uh who's a
perfect 80s Johnny Storm that should be
the easiest one the 80s was right with
joh it's almost too many it's an
abundance of riches 80s Kevin
Bacon but like I think I think the
abundance of riches of the 80s Johnny
Storm but uh uh I think he's the best
casting I think he's got a lot of soft
beautiful sincerity in his eyes but he
comes across brusk I think the thing
needs to have that like Baby Blues but
also have that like emotional way while
being a bit standoffish in a very like
Street um brutality kind of Way's he's a
scrappy guy he says it's clobber in time
like I I think uh he's perfect and he's
so good in the bear that's that's my
favorite of the casting if it's true
terrific yeah and I'm I I am because
it's because he just becomes thing for
once he becomes thing he's just that
form right yeah so like I am intrigued
to see and I hope that you know his
chops really shine through all that and
I oh chrisan later would be a great
Johnny Storm uh I'm I imagine they'll do
a performance capture with that uh and
so I'm just I hope that all of his
greatness can shine through that and
then finally
Joseph Eddie mson from stranger things
season 4 Quinn as Jonathan storm uh you
know he would not have been my first 10
picks but like it's just there's so many
people that read Johnny Storm to me but
he does have a movie star quality that's
undeniable because he you know stranger
things have been going three years all
sudden this guy comes out of nowhere and
that's all anybody's talking about
that's Johnny Storm it's not Johnny
storm in the in the linear sense of like
this is what I picture at all if I'd
seen him abstractly but now that I've
seen his performance and I see his
impact I totally see it it's just funny
that he wouldn't have been in my top 10
until stranger things like I wouldn't
have known that type of guy would work
but I I'm excited it's okay it's okay uh
someone asking if I've seen Kingdom I
adore Kingdom uh yeah I wouldn't have an
Navy Street shirt without Kingdom but
yeah I love the show Kingdom MMA
Jonathan Tucker is one of my favorite
actors Jonathan Tucker I think he's onep
he should be underated like the fact
that Jonathan Tucker isn't uh everywhere
is is it's proof that the system doesn't
work absolutely the truth uh all right
we're going to jump real quick into the
Super chats but of course uh I need to
verify one more thing that I cannot see
right now so give me a hot secundo koi
stall from me koi yeah okay Tom Holland
and Mark wallberg is the entire
Fantastic Four into it my boys John and
Coy where's Gregory Gregory's in a
ton of meetings today yes GRE is
is keeping the life's blood of this
channel coordinated in ways that uh you
know we are incapable yeah there's
there's accounting and there's
slideshows and there's power points um
the most power so he builds up six
villains and have Sinister Six vers
Miles Morales totally an option I do
think by the end of Secret Wars we will
have a Spider-Man in Sony and I think
Miles Morales is a likelihood always
thought Glen pal would be a good how or
even Kyle rer but he could be a great
choice for Johnny Storm uh Glen Powell
man he is Hell Jordan like it's insane
how much he's hell Jordan he's a glen
fighter pilot Powell Jordan oh he is
he's got the Powell of Jordan um yeah
I'd love him over there I love him
anywhere uh koi wise Uncle Ben in uh
Madam Webb not confirmed but I think uh
we will have a Ben over there uh we'll
see we'll see I do think they're
protecting Peter Parker I I don't know
if it's going to be in a parental way
and Uncle way but I think that he is a
fantastic prot Peter Parker I mean it's
it's gonna be a fun little like Wolf and
Cub oh my God how do you guys do this
it's it's a lot how do you guys tell the
date oh yes where is it somewhere oh
look at the photo on the right there we
go boom there it is oh perfect koi image
Coy that's why you're on all these all
the time all right guys give a round of
applause in the chat for Coy leave some
hand emojis or whatever CU we're jumping
into some super chats thank you guys for
being so generous again this really does
help these streams to be proliferated
across the internet in ways that they
can't just on their own so uh you guys
are the knees of bees and uh that's an
anatomically cool thing to to to be um
so yeah anyhow we're going to just
adjust our little screen here and uh
Noah Duncan first and foremost I I would
do the the airhorn um but a month or two
ago our soundboard melted down and it
erased all the fun sound effects we
don't have any fun sound effects no fun
for us yeah no fun till Brooklyn Noah
Duncan thank you so much for
contributing to the chat uh one of two
my pitch here we go co you are a
producer get ready for the green or the
red light tease in iron heart that the
villain is an apprentice with a master
later revealed to be Doom make a Young
Avengers movie where they two of two
fight Doom they go to lat Veria to take
him down he wins and they barely Escape
makes us wonder if the Avengers could
have won and then we go to Secret Wars
love it love it and it gives us like a
somber like oh no we lost kind of ending
again all Infinity War love it
appreciate it I do think they're
steering away from TV setting up movies
though uh that's the only reason that
that might not happen if you'll notice a
lot of the Marvel spotlights they do
seem to be shifting away from that
connectivity being mandatory I think
they could say you know that the Red
Hood has an apprentice I don't think
they'd show him first in the show though
that's why like your addendum making a
Young Avengers movie I think that is
absolutely a great way but the
trickiness there is we haven't had each
young Avenger in their own show enough
to really connect us to them I don't
know if we could really have them jump
into I love Isaiah Bradley Jr
whatever yeah so I think we need I think
Young Avengers is going to be a show uh
and again that does cause a problem for
introducing someone as powerful as Doom
the storyline you've pitched here it's
fantastic I just think the logistics of
where the Optics are on the Disney Plus
shows is is the only thing keeping that
at Bay is just Optics um because Loki is
one of the best things Marvel's ever
done but for some reason people are like
Marvel's dead whether or not they look
at the goodness of what a lot of phase
four and five things have brought us
they just like to you know just say
universally it's all bad it's all it all
sucks Jake I I I just you know I'm I've
been I feel like more lenient towards
this phase than most people you have
true but it's it is interesting it has
it has uh this is sort of a stray topic
so I'll keep it short but it has
illuminated to me the I think the
greater Thing Marvel is in the position
of having to do now where they defined
what the uh broads spanning Cinematic
Universe is for our time in an
unprecedented fashion and they did it in
this kind of perfected not without its
you know bumps but you know in in a
threea kind of way and now I feel like
the onus is to find out how do we do how
do we innovate beyond that cuz I think
there is something maybe a little less
climactic than just like oh yeah we have
another three act set of phases and
they're just bigger you know so I feel
like they are kind of in the position of
having to Define now like how do you
make this shared Endeavor still feel
like a fresh thing and not just like
some franchise now yeah yeah and I think
that's the trickiness but I love this
idea man solid idea absolutely actually
yeah like I I seeing it and having it be
this kind of like I could already
imagine the the emotional flavors going
into that of like the Young Avengers you
know using I I almost thought of one of
those DC animated like Justice League
versus the Teen Titans or something like
that you know which has you know like a
pretty big you know magical threat um
you know that obviously they they are
victorious and I do think iron heart is
going to help set up that magic and
science I mean especially with red hood
and everything else I do think that's
the gateway to Doom I just don't know
how much weight they're going to put on
iron har because of how people are
perceiving the show all the weight Co
all the weight all the weight heyy I
mean I hope may maybe
I my secret hope is that Ekko is like
super good same because it looks pretty
good and and maybe I feel like I don't
know iron heart has been kind of the one
that's been waffling in terms of like
people like she had the intro in wakanda
forever but I feel like a lot of people
were like CG on that like you know I
think there are other things that
distracted from her impact in that movie
trailer d23 was great oh hey it was
really really good like I was shocked by
how much like they got a really cool
sensibility and it felt very Bendis so
I'm I'm after the trailer okay we'll see
I'm I'm hoping that that show comes and
makes a splash and I am curious now to
see how also Marvel yeah adjusts what
the shows are what their function is
also feels crazy to have seen footage
from a show that's still not out yeah
like a year and a half ago hey we just
got this dream boy thank you so much
Steven Yun Sentry is gonna be
amazing okay real quick just describe to
me once again the the core tenants of
centuries character Superman with like a
bipolar disorder order where one side's
evil one side's good Jacqueline hide
Superman I am very excited lightness I
am very excited to see Steven Young play
that because uh on The Walking Dead
Glenn is such a is such an eyeline at
least especially at the beginning uh he
is a very you know good-natured
character and then in other things I've
seen Steven J and I haven't seen beef I
would like to see beef there was all
that controversy surrounding beef so I
didn't watch it at the time uh but I I
get the sense that that is a more sort
of like Gruff uh more of an kind
of character and so uh and so yeah I
think he's got range and I'm definitely
excited to just see him enter and I hope
my main hope is that it's a character
that is significant and important so
that we don't get another one of those
situations where we're like damn you
know they they wasted their this guy
card on oneoff you know or something
like that or or you know on side
character we don't really spend much
time caring about but uh but yeah I'm
glad you're excited dream boy and I'm
I'm rooting for for uh Steven young
because I think he's been terrific and
everything I have seen him in uh sea
payon thank you for joining us in the
super chats my friend keeping the
streams alive The Boys Are Back In Town
the co are back in town Coy and John
love you guys I am genuinely worried
about Marvel right now and I'm in the
camp where I want Kang to stay and they
need to save Doom for Fantastic 4 and
the next
Saga I that's fair I mean it is a
precarious situation and I think this is
kind of an interesting moment to at
least touch on the idea that you know
you could just I don't know could you
recast Kang is there any version in the
next Saga though Secret Wars is like
we're we're building the secret Wars now
are we in Phase five right now yeah okay
so like so you know I mean like we we're
the line between phases four they just
wrote a line later they were like that
seems like a thing well Ant-Man was the
beginning of phase five which was a
silly Choice J Lannister is Dr Doom that
that never happened right Nikolai Koster
Waldo that's I've Just Seen artist MOS
yeah no it's just just an idea uh but
like I I I'm not worried because of all
the pivoting they're doing I mean you
guys were plenty vocal about my thoughts
on the Marvels but I do think what do
you mean let's revisit that I'm still
tired um but I do think that it is
learning from its mistakes I do think
that it is I mean it's had a big
overhaul in in the creative side it's
had a big overhaul in the suit side I do
think that the six months of cap 4
re-shoot are a good thing so I I'm not
worried yet I think Deadpool 3 is GNA be
amazing I'm not worried at all about
Deadpool 3 and everything coming out
after it like there's a few things I'm
like I wouldn't have done that but I'm
not worried um but I I do think it's
easy to to look at the negative it's
louder so I think it's very you know
easy to get clicks by saying like you
know the sky is falling I think it's
very easy to go like this is but like
Guardians just made $800 million uh
Spider-Man was two years ago not even
like like a year and a half ago um if
another Studio had a billion dollar hit
a year and a half ago not a single
person would be saying it's failing a
billion dollars and then another movie
that made 800 million yes it's not
making a billion dollars a movie but if
if any franchise had an a billion dollar
hit followed by an $800 million doll hit
no one would be saying yeah it's
crazy that's fair that's fair it's it is
it is stange like it it is an
interesting time because yeah it does
seem like they aren't on as assured
footing but yeah that the whole like
burning down I'm like there I did I I I
think that was your was maybe was your
Tweet where it's like literally like a
tandem of like oh this one is dead this
one oh it's back this one's dead it's
back you know it's killing it's like any
artist that changes their sound for the
second album like you got to get
comfortable and like and my only concern
is Marvel knee-jerk reacting and then
not being as bold in the future okay
yeah yeah and I mean you know they they
are certainly adjusters but u i I trust
Marvel to at least adjust with some
level of poise they seem to want to take
their time as opposed to maybe brothers
who seems apt to be like change it just
change it sh it put in the VA change it
what did Marvel do change it dude that
uh that Acme movie I literally gonna
whoever buys it I have amca list and
whenever I go to a press screening I
always buy the movie ticket in a list so
I can support the movie still that movie
anytime I have any extra rollover like
if I if I've only seen one movie that
week I'm getting two tickets to act me
like I'm I'm going to support the
out of the movie cuz what they did
to those poor creators so I'm going to
make sure that movie makes as much money
as I can personally make you know
somebody used the the metaphor of of
it's it's kind of like burning your
house down for the insurance money and I
like it is kind of exactly like we lost
all this money on this movie cuz we
couldn't put it out even though we house
on fire so stupid yeah it's got it we
got to change that law yeah cuz cuz my
boy zaz left he's got love love him love
he's going to play Dr Dr he is right now
a dictator in a country trying to make
things his way yeah no he's doing a good
job quote blink got some love for Coy's
comic Corner in the chat the strike's
over we got we got ideas we got things
cooking also that's great question we
got some ideas we'll probably be
dropping another episode very soon that
was actually shot before the strike
looking forward to it good all right
well yeah I mean you know we'll see I
yeah I I certainly wish we lived on a
timeline where there was no Jonathan
major controversy and that we could just
enjoy this Kang stuff uh but I don't
know I'll wait and see it's it's one of
those things where yeah I'm like this
could be precarious but I still have
enough faith in Marvel to like think
this through and I do think that a
benefit of their extreme wealth or at
least Kevin feige's extreme you know
predilection for for thinking way down
the line thinking ahead is helpful for
stuff like this so you know we'll see
hopefully it'll be good Frank C 2002
thank you for being here and
contributing to the chat did you see the
new new pick of Corin sweat he is swole
I haven't have you I have he was Corin
sweating in the gym uh no he looks huge
I'm uh I'm stoked for him um like any
anytime Googling David Corin sweat buff
anytime an actor gets told they're not
big enough and then immediately puts in
the work for three months I'm like
goddamn right uh maybe try today's date
okay buff that's that's a picture of
Henry caval and a picture of uh of other
Superman all right buff November 17
there he is four hours ago there it is
this one look at that sweat
look at my man right here yeah he's
getting it you can see those arms
through the shirt yep that's good he
good he's getting them gains I respect
it absolutely Man David G gain viid
Corin sweat I mean the thing is like it
really is so much aggressive nutrition
and training that you can gain so much
mass in three months with uh the right
team and I know people are going to be
like steroids I don't know if he's on
steroids or not I just know it is
possible so gu in the movies kale true
ask anybody as long as you're getting
filmed it's legal that's right but like
you can also like I've never taken a St
at a day in my life and I stay pretty
big uh I don't have the money for
steroid that's all I do and I've gained
nothing yeah I should maybe try diet and
exercise May it's a different angle
everybody's got to mix it up you know we
do what we can Sam spring doing what he
can to keep this chat alive love you and
appreciate you you got a very affable a
lot of you guys you guys got good nice
yeah faces on these all the ones today
so far pleas PE wholesome in the chat
Coy you were quickly becoming one of my
favorite people to hear talk about
Marvel hey I'm manifesting peaceful and
positive chat today what a positive vibe
for the positive face we're just it's
working it's happening quick it's
working look at this I appreciate you
very much positivity shabby I woke up
last Saturday like giddy I was in such a
good mood I literally tweeted how happy
I was you know how often I like go like
what a glorious I was Joseph Gordon L
and 500 Days of Summer before the
breakup where he's just like singing to
animated animal you you were day
in the life but only the second part
where the Paul McCartney bit comes just
woke up got out of bed ran a com across
my head and just like birds brought you
coffee Disney birds yeah and I exposed
myself to the vitrol and today is the
opposite I came in here very neutral and
you guys have been great so you're
actually uplifting you're putting us in
a positive trajectory so I appreciate
you there are no women in the news to
bring things down
no women except for Madam web which is
the greatest trailer of all time yeah I
found it when I was in the amaz
researching spiders with myom right
after Mom his mom also not a woman cuz
that would be too woke to involve a
woman mother yes all these people that
think women shouldn't be in properties
are born to only two men n James Remar
is going to be Captain miss m mom into
that into that all these people are like
like the the the story of Wonder Woman
originally where it's like Hercules made
me out of clay yes I don't know any
women I want that version where and I
think they're going to do that for James
guns get this though I want it Hercules
made me out a clay okay and the whole
time sorry I meant say Zeus but Hercules
came out Zeus you know what I'm saying
it's fine you're not the Greek mythology
ex don't ask about that stuff although
those guys consist in Marvel so you are
an IDI are is idiot and a shill and a
fake fan that's true uh what were we
talking about I don't know I got lost in
shill I forgot who I was supposed to
shill to yes well anyway there was a
good joke in there somewhere maybe it'll
come back to it'll rhyme when you cycle
back to it yes well thank you for
manifesting a a delightful uh chat today
it is certainly working oh God it's GNA
kill me yeah what the joke was going to
be where you were going with it yeah we
had Madam web's mom and women and oh
that's what I want okay here we go Zeus
builds Diana out of clay and then the
rest of the movie every character is an
actor except Diana who is Ray Harry how
and style
clation old school into that into that
still voiced by G not as much of a joke
as it is a pitch and I'm into it
honestly it would be strange and the
only way you could do it nowadays is
like as a short and I think it's
hilarious I think it would in some ways
it could be like an actually endearing
thing and those are the kinds of
contributions I bring to the superhero
genre I support this creativity thank
you Coy I support you being alive that's
good I need to be uh I'm going to do my
best
jasel cool name or is it like or do you
have to swallow that and just make it
like jel like what happens like what
happens like in in your neck of the the
country where you just freaking swallow
entire halves of words Worchester NOP
it's Worcester kid somehow all those
letters just blur together PE wer wubber
Su of
them Jas Elara name
thank you thank you for being here thank
you for for putting up with us and let
us know if you're in the chat uh you
know if we if we got your name right cuz
uh you know we want to make everybody
feel represented properly name an MCU
movie that you would have taken in a
completely different direction and why
and how would your new version affect
current day continuity this is a great
question and I am going to have to think
on that cheapers kristo I mean I'd have
Quantum Mania involved time you got a
Time conqueror and you got a man a man
who's missing time with his daughter
because of the blip a daughter that's
growing up rapidly and there's nothing
scarier to a parent than losing time
with their kid and you have a villain
involving time and you don't use time he
doesn't use time when he comes out of
the quantum realm it doesn't talk about
missing time that he'd missed like maybe
time dispersal like an Interstellar
different when you're in there he time
conqueror doesn't use time as a weapon
in the prison he instead uses like weird
telekinesis to hold her up against the
wall and they wrote a line of dialogue
where it's like time doesn't work in the
Quant Mania they literally negated
ant-man's Powers by making they're
nothing to scale so when Cassie grows
giant everything's tiny so she's
literally just tiny so why would she
need orange slices cuz she's tiny tiny
now a little less tiny making your giant
in a Quantum realm and then they negate
Kang's Powers by putting in a place
where time is relative indifferent so it
is a movie that negates everyone's
powers and then Kang fights
technologically advanced millions of
civilizations Evolution ants uh I would
change a lot about that movie uh just
off the top of my head that'd be one I
would change okay uh I would
change uh I I would change Infinity wor
an endgame I would make them one movie I
would cut it down to like two hours and
uh and that will affect pretty much
everything coming out I I think that
would probably end the MCU right there I
think you just burned it down I think
you just I think you just got that
insurance money what I think you just AC
me movi that whole story I don't know if
I would have taken
itel there we goel there you go awesome
beautiful want to call that didn't me
interrupt your PCT that good I apprciate
you doing that um
I might have
it's weird because there's so many of
the movies that I would take in a
slightly different direction but like
the core nuts and Bol like I can't I'm
trying to think of one where like the
entire premise I would have just changed
outright like Multiverse of Madness
comes to mind only in that I like the
flavors of what that movie did but the
story within it uh I it's that movie
that feels like you're in a multiv I've
used this metaphor before it's like
everything everywhere all at once feels
feels like the definitive movie about
this multiversal story whereas
Multiverse of Madness feels like you
know a version of what this could be but
it doesn't feel like the version of what
this could be so I I would have just
taken that movie and like retooled it
kept the Sam Ramy kept the you know
horrific and and kind of slapstick
quality but I don't know I would have I
almost would have made it sort of like
skip right to incursions get Clea in
there and let's do that thing I would
have made it a what if or sure make it a
what if or something like that CU then
the what if show becomes more impactful
and then you have Sam rainy getting more
freedom I feel like Sam Ry got kind of
handcuffed in the edit he got to make
obviously the movie he wanted it's very
much the Sam Ry movie but I would have
let him have even more fun and called it
a what if yeah that's a good that's a
good call I think yes in some way or
another I would have retooled that movie
because I also would have cast variants
and Bruce Campbell would have been a
doctor strange
variant imagine the end how much funnier
that joke is if he's a drant yes oh my
God little tweaks guys my God Kevin you
have my number get into the Marvel Koy
holy crap and I could write a
dissertation on what to do with the
Marvel and then I would just squeeze in
a whole other movie about Wanda so that
when we eventually get the dark the dark
the Scarlet Witch turn then it makes a
bit more you could rush to it through
that and then you do the long game with
ours yeah so that's what we would do H I
notice you hey I don't know there's a
blue check or there's a check next to
his name and he got a hat on and uh and
on your left we got yeah I like both of
these avatars here you guys are killing
the game hael thank you so much uh
raccoon shampoo with all the additions
thank you by the way for being here with
all the additions to the Superman legacy
cast how big of a role do you think the
extra superheroes like Hawk Girl and
metamorpho will play uh I don't think
there'll be huge Parts I think it's
setting up a universe I think there's
going to be a world where uh we're
meeting a Clark Kent that is
establishing himself as a super and he's
going to be dealing with his family at
the Daily Planet his family back on the
farm and his family of Heroes I think
it's going to be if you look at what
James gun does he's so good at making
movies about people that feel like
Outsiders finding their family I think
Superman is going to be the ultimate
story of an eyeline for us as people to
understand Superman by way of him
feeling like an outsider finding his
family I think all of these cast members
are being cast as a large Justice League
family that's going to further populate
the DCU but I don't think they're going
to have a lot of screen time I I think
there's going to be an amazing moment or
two with them but uh I don't think
they're going to be like it's not going
to be a 4our movie and I don't think
they're going to be um you know as an
individual important but I think the
family and moments with them is going to
be big I think if anyone's going to have
a big role from the plot that I have in
my head it'll be Mr terrific I would
love that from from our exposes in the
animated Stu think it's gonna be that's
a character I'm I'm definitely excited
to see and I and I will be curious to
see how James gun's Universe handles it
it certainly seems like Superman will be
entering a universe that already has
plenty of metahumans and other things
like that um so G ghost hey buddy how
you doing we'll get we'll get to we'll
get there we're we're we're powering
through also Sam Thomas I've been
wanting um Leith as uh as brother Voodoo
ever since I saw the first five I saw
the whole movie but within five minutes
of Haunted Mansion I was like brother
Voodoo like he's so good 15 seconds
brother Voodoo brother Voodoo is a
another uh Magic wielder Allah doctor
strange but with a lot more uh cultural
history tied to like and the afterlife
and things are in that world and brother
Voodoo is in some ways more powerful
than doctor strange and he's a little
bit more interesting a character and and
I think that the Lei being woke Coy I
know I know saying white people are the
most interesting I relate to all of them
and only them and only them and I can't
even understand what characters are
saying when they're not white that's
true or or a guy as guy Richie those
white people speak so
clearly uh I love that when I watch a
guy Richie movie I'm like the only one
I'm like translating my friends what
they're saying because I I can't stand
watching with subtitles it drives
me crazy uh that said uh brother
Voodoo uh I think Leith Stanfill with a
mix between his role in Haunted Mansion
and Atlanta oddly enough darus would be
so special absolutely quick shout out in
the live chat zor Cino Severino Jr uh
says that the hints that Dr Doom is
coming can be felt in even in Loki
season 2 science and fiction I'm I'm not
I wanted to read this all smooth like
science and fiction magic and science
that's basically what Doom works with
and I mean and green and green yes well
and that's the other thing is uh before
we move on to the next one uh just I do
feel like the ending of lowkey even
though it seems like the show and movie
interplay may be whittel down moving
forward it does seem like you could uh
I'm sorry Maria Jose uh I want I want to
say all the names right but I just can't
understand what you're saying I got to
get the the Babble I gotta get the DU
lingo for woman woman yeah so do a lot
of YouTubers J to the k um but but yeah
the ending of Loki seems like you could
use that as you know a segue out for K
basically you know um but that's neither
here nor there ATM ion BOS thank you for
joining us contributing I keep trying to
say two words at once and just thrown
you off and just The Duality of language
has Greg thought about me joining the
Channel I would love to be a part of the
channel Ian blush uh you know the
contracts are in your inbox you just got
to sign them send in your blood sample
uh the Xerox of your Social Security
card your birth certificate your
mother's maid name uh your bank routing
number and account info you just need
all that stuff and then you will be a
real reject that's all it takes anyone
can join really but uh but yes we will
have you and you'll take over Coy's
comic corner so it'll be um I in blos
comic Corner cool name you know it's
good it it rings and uh we're looking
forward to having you and Greg I know is
counting on you you're going to be
taking on a lot of the responsibilities
that he has so instead of him not being
on this live stream it could be you oh
look he's here now to hire you oh hey
he's here he's ready to bring you in
fresh haircut all it takes he just pops
in that was the meeting he was in it was
clearing your paperwork it was a
haircut yeah he was clearing your
paperwork so you're a member of the
channel
now uh and that could be fake you don't
even know if he's actually here yeah
that's true you could just be no he is I
was actually talk one of his cats cidra
zi how you doing thank you for keeping
the stream live today I missed last
week's live and let me tell you it was
calm you should have been there right it
didn't open with a lot of profanity did
not uh descend into GRE and I didn't
back and forth get angry and switch and
keep each other sane no no you know I I
should have been there for you guys as
an Anor I should have been there for
well you know you might have also would
have been the weird well yeah I mean it
would have inevitably descended into
madness but I feel like I might have
been the intermediary because it would
have been very funny because you know I
liked the movie A might more than it's a
mess but I liked it more I guess but
either way that's neither here nor there
uh do you think this is the last time we
see Loki and which was your favorite
episode uh I don't but I don't I think
Tom Hon's comments are you know on point
he's like I think it would be foolish to
assume this is the last of Loki I don't
expect to see a lot of him immediately
or anything like that but I think that
he's gonna be on hand and I think that
it's smart to give him something that
does feel like a sendoff they said we
wanted these two seasons of Loki to
function like you know the halves of a
complete story I think that is a
beautiful choice for the MCU because it
allowed them great storytelling that
didn't have to be open to editing down
the line uh but yeah I I just wouldn't
expect to see him a ton for the time
if we see him I think it'll be something
like SE your ORS maybe to give that that
Thor moment I'd rather not see him again
I love Tom Edon as Thor but my love for
him is why I want him to have an ending
and I feel like that ending is way too
beautiful and perfect same reason I
don't want Downey back yeah and and I
mean the difference to me it's easier to
bring him back than dowy though make
that clear sure yeah yeah yeah and I
think it's good that they're not being
like he's officially dead like you know
they've moved on like there's something
about uh having like Downey and Chris
Evans and and some of the majors be like
they've moved on they're done
and it's like you know there's the heavy
strong rumors that they're going to at
least come back for Secret Wars and
stuff like that and and you could forgo
that conclusion you know that seems like
something we could easily add up but
there is something about that where it's
like announcing that they are done you
know I think you are maybe in some cases
better off doing it more like Tom Heston
just leave it kind of let the character
rest and let people speculate from there
yeah and that that ending was perfect uh
and episode six of both seasons are two
of my favorite hours of Marvel ever 100%
episode six is perfect yeah and I mean
like I love both seasons and that's it's
easily my favorite MCU show uh and that
finale of season 2 especially uh was was
such a lovely moment to me because it
was like everything I hoped that this
story could be for the MCU but it also
just did stuff that I like about good
Sci-Fi and and interesting and and
emotional sci-fi in general beyond all
that like if this was just its own
isolated show I feel like I would still
have been just as Dazz L and wrapped up
in all the circumstances M um and yeah
that finale was was was pretty poetry so
hell's yeah raccoon shampoo back in
Action thank you for being so generous
as to come back in twice I think it
might have gone
WR take two I think it might have gone
over my head but do you think when and
where Loki got those P but you know when
where Loki got those Powers I got you I
got you hey it's proof for life proof
for life that's right I did that on it's
like when people sing Different lyrics
you're like oh wow this crazy it's not a
backing track she put Kelsey in this
this week's song T Taylor's version oh
look out that's right that's right she's
not gay you heard it here I mean she's
got like I'm just I'm worried for him
cuz he's he's about to be lyrics in a
breakup song I'm just I'm always worried
for anyone dating Taylor Swift for the
Future album it's okay I hope they live
happily ever after I just hope that they
get input on what the song will that's
that's my favorite version of The
Narrative is if she chooses them
specifically cuz it's like we're going
to write this song together it's going
to be about how you Muse like a
relationship Muse yeah but they but they
have some kind of like like no like yeah
some uh autonomous contribution to the
song somehow so it's like these weird
collaborations that then make you know
everybody dog pile Jake Gyllenhaal real
rejects Taylor's version we're gonna put
a red script a red scarf in the graphic
it's coming get ready for the iror React
videos the amount of people that like
every time I interview Jake are like you
ask about the scarf no I will not that
man is living his life you let him if he
ever comes on that's a great question
I'm be
like uh but do we know back to your
question Ron sorry do you know when and
where Loki got those new powers I
thought they fixed his time
slipping um so uh the idea being that
the the time slipping they think they
fixed it it comes back he learns how to
harness it or at least they make it like
latent and then my interpretation sure
as soon as we stabbed Kang or he who
remains it caused the time slipping cuz
he
was at the end of time and he didn't
willingly come back to where he was and
I think that Kang he who remains did
that on purpose in order for Loki to get
the ability by learning it he set him on
the path to learn that skill he wouldn't
have learned the skill if he didn't time
slip sure and that's something that I do
want to go back and rewatch the season I
want to watch one and two back to back
too because it is one or Boris and it is
it is and I could be wrong uh we I one
of the things I love I love watching the
show for you guys but one of the things
I do struggle with is uh you know when
we're watching it and we're commentating
because we have to because otherwise
it's watching us stare blankly ahead uh
sometimes I miss little moments where
I'm like oh I'm assessing something and
I'm putting theories together based off
most of what I've gathered but you can't
like I'm getting like 80% of the show
when we're watching it with lights in
our faces so I'm sure I missed something
and I'm hoping that's not what I missed
there's a real difference yeah between
watch live first time commentary versus
commentary on something that you're
already familiar with uh Seattle Chaos's
temp hat and the time Loom gave him the
powers so that's a possible explanation
there uh at Joan love says uh Billy
Porter for Dr for Reed Richards I'm with
it yes Billy Porter always with the
beautiful dresses too uh well from pose
is it the show it's the show about
Dragon Queens I think yeah Billy Porter
picture of a beautiful hat but also
maybe beautiful dresses all all the
above Billy Porter Billy Porter got the
the drips for days got Poise oh yeah I
want Billy Porter Reed Richards and I
want Billy Porter to supply uh his or
their own wardrobe that's Porter for
dazzler o Taylor Swift can be another
version 5 seconds on dazzler 5 seconds
on dazzler a uh uh imagine if Jubilee's
powers also involve turning stuff into
like music into telekinetic light and
and impact music as a through line I'm
here for it and and she's a pop star so
like if if you know the biggest pop star
of the world was also a mutant with
awesome powers more music battles in the
MCU that was that's one thing I wouldn't
change about Multiverse and Madness uh
is that uh yeah is that you know they
had that music fight and that was pretty
cool that's true I love that moment
um yes yeah uh and so yeah um anyhow I
do like Matt Smith as a as R Richards as
well I've seen that a couple times today
I would have loved that oh yeah oh yeah
I mean you know there have been good
choices Matt Smith would have been
really cool Adam Driver I think was a
solid pick been watching a lot of people
do Adam Driver Impressions on the
internet which are funny I didn't think
at first I was like what would that even
be
got now I know exactly what it
is uh somebody did him ordering a pizza
and I can't do it but it was just sort
of something like I want a medium Pizza
extra
sauce so this his intonation it was it
was good uh ferret land 98 uh we're
going to take this one and then we're
going to see what we got over in the
streamlabs real quick um fretland 98 the
inner mations of my mind are an enigma
John knows who said this right I got you
do you I actually don't yeah that's
uh I don't know how I would ever draw oh
there are two superheroes in the show uh
actors or actual superheroes they're
actual superheroes Co okay Mermaid Man
and Barnacle
Boy oh why do I know that you will kick
yourself when you realize how ubiquitous
the property they come from
is man par I can picture them like their
suits they're there are lots of nautical
nonsense that follow these guys I give
up I I'm GNA be vexed for too long they
uh don't live in a pineapple under the
sea but they're nearby I never
with SpongeBob no Coy why I just find it
like really sophomoric in in a way that
didn't like appeal like I'm really hard
with comedy like I don't watch a lot of
comedy and I don't rewatch comedy almost
ever like I think I think um Shane black
and Martin mcdunn are the only two
people that write comedy that like fits
me um I'll watch like a comedy in
theaters very yeah like I'll watch a
comedy in theaters once and I can like
laugh with the audience and enjoy that
Joy but like the average comedy on TV
I'm I'm like I just feel like an a I
feel like cell I feel like I'm like I
understand these people most of the time
but right now I'm a little outside my
depth and I just don't get yeah yeah
that's fair and uh SpongeBob especially
I just like it felt very like oh I'm I'm
losing time like I'm I only have I only
have 24 hours in the day and I only have
uh you know at at best 100 years to live
why am I spending it here
evil say the chat uh Coy and most of the
time people are like try their show and
I was like I sorry I tried COI now is
the time if you weren't there as a kid
you're going to you're going to connect
with it now as an adult man guys we're
all dying so so I would recommend doing
other things the four of us are dying
all righty uh remember we left off at
ferret land on the soups let's check in
with the stream Libs real quick cuz we
got a few more than a few we got a
handful and I love a handful boy nuts
are good in a handful uh you know uh
rumors are good in a handful uh goodness
gracious me okay I know what to do I
just got to use my ey eyeballs that's
all we do here Koy is use our eyeballs
uh hey we got
dunun okay let's let's see here dun 8290
let's see there thank you by the way for
jumping in on the streamlabs kick us off
M AI which is an Abie that you can
decipher on your own there are a lot of
people saying that the MCU fell off but
I think it's just a stumble do you think
Deadpool is going to be the movie to
totally pull the MCU back out of its rut
if you can even consider this a rut uh I
think like all roller coasters it it's
high it's low it has little bumps in the
middle I think we're in in the bumps but
I don't think it's a rut because rut
implies stopping even even my least
favorite uh Marvel films are at least
you know something worth watching and
enjoying so I don't think it stopped uh
it's I don't think it fell off I do
think it's been more experimental I
think it's been more ambitious I do
think it had the biggest two h in the
entertainment industry in the last 20
years um between the pandemic and the
strike like those are huge roadblocks
and whenever those equivalent stumbles
happened before um there wasn't a shared
universe and there wasn't this giant
machine like so I don't think it's fair
and like I said earlier um a billion
dollar movie a year and a half ago and
an $800 million doll movie this year are
certainly not like those are insane
numbers uh but people don't think that
way they think about the last five
minutes because we're all
dying yeah
remember that yeah yeah do something fun
today we're all dying I don't know I
mean I am not personally counting on
Deadpool is not the character nor is the
the movie that I would rely on to set
like the overall continuity back in line
just because I associate the character
and the presence with being so anarchic
and I know that they're going to be
doing a bunch of stuff with the fox
Universe I can see how Deadpool 3 May
sort of set and and kind of um I don't
know kind of BR all together I think
it's gonna be it's G to be like the
beginning of us getting the the map
theyve they've started drawing and the
co and the and the like definitive
Collision of X-Men Fox stuff with the
new MCU we get to mour Fox which we
never got to do like between dark
Phoenix and the way they released mean
like our la like the last two Fox the
fox Universe gave us so much I maintain
they were not great X-Men movies but
damn they were good mutant movies and
I'm really and Logan's exceptional but I
do think that Deadpool is a highlight
like Logan is and they deserve that
Bittersweet beauty that Deadpool is his
comedy comes from a place of trauma and
the X-Men are a traumatic world I'm
excited for them to get their swans song
yes I am as well and uh and I'm excited
to see what I know they've said you know
part of this maybe or speculation says
that part of this maybe yeah come
figuring out through the Multiverse how
we're going to kind of pick and choose
what we want to keep and then kind of
melt all that into a new somewhat sacred
timeline yeah um and I think that could
be an interesting and fun thing and I do
see a Deadpool movie doing that at at
the very least and it will be too it's
unprecedented because we haven't seen
Deadpool as part of the MCU yet so you
know I am still while being of that
opinion I'm still waiting to see what
Deadpool's interaction now that he's
home you will be like uh wait before you
scroll this next one says no need to
advertise I don't know if they want us
to avoid it but good God look at that oh
my goodness I think that they maybe they
want their privacy but we should we
should let them know thank you
yes yeah I don't you know what I
mean like I don't know how to handle so
shy to swear on camera now we're an hour
in I checked for I said you know we
we'll be discreet uh uh can I at least
shout your name I don't know they said
not to don't all right well well maybe
they they are okay with that hey CW it's
a great Network unrelated to anything CW
is a fantastic Network super so
appreciative of the CW I mean and that
those those four words could mean
something totally different but I that's
how I'm reading it oh 100% you know what
I mean but now we're giving the CW some
love yes absolutely the CW doesn't need
commercials not at all no but we
appreciate the CW very much oh my god
dude thank you for being here uh if
you're still in the stream sound off uh
I'm assuming that's what that means yeah
yeah yeah yeah I just happy seriously I
I am overwhelmed because I haven't been
in the chair for this uh so yeah thank
you so much dude thank you for being a
good human I know we joke about it all
the time on the shoutouts and stuff um
but yeah like I don't know you are one
of the more inspiring members of the
reject nation and you take such good
care of us you are so yeah generous with
your time and your energy and uh yeah
I'm just saying Smallville started you
know the superhero TV movement in a big
and that was on the CW back when it was
the WB that weird little frog and then
Supernatural was there and that just
kept content going then it had a
shortlived sequel and to this day those
two guys are great I don't even know I
didn't never watch Supernatural but I
watched that out of a jensenackles
uh Jared padaki Tik Tok tell you what
yeah oh yeah guys are Delights pad talk
they charm and Carnet charm Karm man all
right well thank you buddy appreciate
you we are humbled uh to say the least
uh here even for discretion I'm just
saying I assume off real quick and we're
going to scroll we're going to scroll uh
we're going to hopefully protect your
privacy uh and and that's the
way no I'm not gonna I'm not going to
pit generosity against generosity um but
especially yeah uh you know the
discretion you know you're you're you're
a lovely hearted dude and we're grateful
and and blessed to have you uh the gamer
MJ we are grateful and blessed to have
you as well love you guys I loved the
Marvels top five films of the year and
I'm not being factious cuz I enjoyed the
Marvels at least on various levels uh
how many movies have you seen this year
uh not not to say that it would Del
legit you know yeah I taste is
subjective but uh but I'm curious as to
what else would be ranked and I am
thrilled truthfully honestly uh I'm glad
that so many people are loving and
having fun with it controversial I know
but did you hear that Steven young is
Century be interesting to see how they
make him the Thunderbolts villain and
how they will uh and how they will the
void and if they'll rcon his origin
story uh the void is his dark side like
that's the evil side of cry cry is good
void is bad um I'm curious what origin
they have I do think it'll be
interesting to see Sentry because he's
so powerful like I got to be honest I've
never really understood the love for
Century because he's just Superman with
Darkness but um I I I think it'll be
interesting to see if they can make me
like a character that I didn't
particularly love like and that's the
fun of these movies is sometimes it can
show me a more lean version of a of a
character that I can you know really
appreciate so I'm hopeful for that with
Sentry um and we'll see what they do for
origin mixing him with some Thunderbolts
goodness I'm excited I'm excited
especially if he is like kind of the
main I don't know antagonistic Force
yeah or something like that you know and
and a character who gets to play
multiple sides of a personality let's
get that James Mack of boy split energy
going except only two personal but still
big difference still impressive all
right Tom Hardy did that movie Nobody
liked but he was good in it he was two
guys well then Coy liked it I didn't see
it so I don't know I didn't I don't know
it's not like exceptional but it's like
a good time but it's because of the Tom
Hardy performance obviously I'll accept
it I'll accept it Coy Ronin te thank you
for joining in on the streams y'all got
oh we can it's just so much bigger here
it's so much bigger here y'all got the
drip today looking good thank you
appreciated color coordinated and we're
bouncing off each other's color purple
and green we're doing the the like Loki
and K colors as well as the purple and
green opposite ends the color spectrum I
think perf and then you know got a
little bit of this yeah you look like
the stor you do look like loed out right
now I also brought very bright green
shoes which are not currently on cuz
it's a shoes off place but okay you are
very much coordinated and we appreciate
it y'all got the drip today looking good
so I haven't seen many Marvel movies and
I barely read the comics so I had a
question what kind of a character is
Reed Richards compared to someone like
doom and who would you all want to play
him I assume y'all mean Doom uh because
or I mean you know we we' we've well
Trot in who we would like to see as Reed
and who may be read now but yeah who
would you like to see as doom and and
just a real quick because we have been
over at least elements of this
aggressively arrogant all powerful uh
dictator is doom and uh Reed is an
aggressively arrogant smartest man in
the room that knows it who is a family
man but often realizes that he's been
negligent to his family at his own good
like he tries to be good and he's a he's
it's Marvel's first family he's the
patriarch but he gets wrapped up in
science and equations and stuff a lot
and uh so he's a dad that you know is a
little absent-minded Professor but
instead of like you know the fun hyinks
it's like what have I done and uh at
times he goes a little e evil becomes
the maker but most the heroes in Marvel
eventually go evil because they've been
running 60 years um who I'd want to play
Doom um I've always wanted Rufus Sul um
he's uh the Knight the evil Knight in a
Knights tale yes I'm a big Rufus Sul guy
uh I wanted someone a little bit more
unknown to get like you know that
because Marvel does really well at
casting character uh actors that are
really talented that aren't household
names and elevating them into household
name and I feel like Rufus Su is
absolutely that he's also got the
physicality he's a bigger guy uh he and
Heath Ledger are also the reason there's
David Bowie in a nights tale they paid
for those music writs out of their own
pocket which I uh which I adore I've
interviewed Rufus a couple times and he
always tells me one new on nights tale
fact because he knows how obsessed I am
and this most recent time we spoke he
was like you know and I was like that's
the cool like he's that cool of a guy
but he plays that Darkness well so I got
a love for lot of love for Rufus just as
a person and gets coffee at my coffee
shop too so I see him sometimes I'm like
that's a night um just saw that me and
Andrew Gordon just watched that a month
or two ago that F first time it was
beautiful that's one of my favorite like
beautiful movie yeah Heath uh Heath's
the reason I got into the entertainment
industry and that movie and 10 things
were a big part of that so I got to see
10 those movies are like but yeah Rufus
um I I if Ben Foster was a foot taller I
think he's got that incredible manic
voice that isn't quite the right thing
for Doom but I want to see him in the
MCU so he's someone I just throw around
there a lot um I think Doom's voice is
so so important it's got to be like
powerful and billowing um so It's Tricky
man but yeah ruus Grand
obviously CGI Beast himself yes hey you
know we could do it like Andy Circus and
King Kong be a great Doom if they had a
different body form yeah you know I mean
you could you wouldn't be able to hear
that it's claw in there just have a I
mean yeah you would have totally
different ACC you know be a great Doom
he's already heimel but man
he's the body The Voice the presence I
mean that's one of those cast like I
love him as heimdal but it's also one of
those castings where you're like you
could be doing more with Ed
but that's why like in the third movie
they're like give them stuff to do yeah
who else would be good uh yeah it's got
to be the physicality it's got to be the
voice it's got to be like all
encompassing I'm gonna think on it while
we while we do this yeah I like that
Tory Jerry in the chat just said uh what
is it read is Tony Stark if he was a
s I'm down for that
interpretation uh Bucky Barnes at also
wants to know who's the superhero you
would like uh all to you would all like
to see a better version of in the chat
uh so I mean we can think on but that's
mainly to the chat yeah uh you know I I
need me an X-Men cartoon version of
Archangel and the Iceman says Bucky
Barnes so think about those
recasts uh and uh we're going to move on
to oh yeah that was my number one pick
in the video I made about Doom was vgo
Mortenson oh yeah look at that I forgot
about my own pick Seattle thank you yeah
go back you got to watch some KO I got
you should check out Ko's comic corner
to see what past Koy had to say
absolutely presid Koy is tired and he
forgot past Coy's thought it's okay
Pedro pass Koy Ah mock or ma absolutely
loving the Madagascar series y'all have
been doing thank you very much those
have been fun a nice surprise I remember
as a as a lad when they were coming out
in the theaters I was like and uh and
now I'm regretting that choice but I'm
also grateful for that choice because it
means we can do it here yeah it's weird
there was a time in the earlier days of
the channel it would always be like I I
feel like I gotta you know have the
utmost knowledge of every film and I'm
always feeling embarrassed for the
things I haven't seen and now it's the
complete opposite where it's like I'm so
glad there are so many things I haven't
seen um but yes could we get a Penguins
of Madagascar Christmas special reaction
it's got the old lady in it uh we'll see
we've got uh the third one in the works
we'll see how that does and uh you know
we got Christmas season coming up I
don't know exactly what the schedule is
going to be but there's definitely going
to be some holiday and Christmas Cent
content and if the Madagascar keep on
chugging I would at least imagine that
it is a distinct possibility and I
appreciate I'm going to screenshot this
as a suggestion just in case cuz that
old lady uh she's throwing down and
she's got good survivalism skills too so
you know I want to go through like
Christmas movies I haven't seen I want
to like try to hone in on some Christmas
First Time watches there's got to be
stuff I've missed oh most certainly
Samesies dude uh hey Mr Juan iar first
want to send you both some love not just
me uh I really appreciate the positivity
you both bring to the world oh thank you
appreciate it it's it's hard work uh if
Mersa Ali decides to drop out of Blade
who would you want to fill the role my
vote would be for Le key Stanfield I was
going to joke Leith Stanfield just
because I feel like he would be a very
chill and sort of like reserved blade um
although I mean you know again I would
be excited to see him play
a something a little bit more more not
that blade is like a bombastic character
necessarily but somebody a little bit
more beyond the energy register that I
associate with him yeah I think of is
like a Carnage uh Joker Vibe that's why
brother voodo if you made him more
energetic but like I don't know blad's
got an intimidation Factor that's like
really intense that's why Wesley Snipes
was so good because that dude's so
intense and like he's so joyous but he's
still got that like you know he can be
he can be very terrifying give me boa uh
I just boa seems so like Pleasant and
happy
that's fair see I got to know him as
Moses so I got to know
Gruff block I could see it uh but it's
not the perfect yeah I'd have to think
on that and put it to the chat as well
if Marshall Ali leaves who should be
blade I already I already cast him
earlier but my boy Yaya I'm always gonna
cast man Yaya's so good he he's he took
over from Morpheus he could do blade
yeah he could do blade uh I feel like
there's another good choice that I'm
just missing right now uh so you know if
it comes back to me obviously Francis
yes uh UFC fighter he's a beast I mean
I'm I'm acting is more important than
physicality but I love that pick I'd
love him as a variant for a couple
scenes hey Gom films in the chat go
check out Gom films does some hilarious
dub videos among other things uh I love
it vampires I don't I'm trying to think
of what the what way I'm supposed to
read this and if I'm missing a reference
so uh oh my God no May can't click too
many things
uh gagh is Andress is into the yah oh
John David
Washington uh I don't hear his voice as
blaz I hear his dad's voice when he
speaks and it's very distracting for
because like I watching T and I was like
this guy's great and then I was like I
feel like I'm watching Denzel in a movie
20 years ago Will Smith blade I like it
I think that we we as as he makes the
soundtrack Michael B Jordan for blade
why not just keep on uh anas If Venom 3
leaks are true
two things first I will be seated also
one thing thank you uh I will be seated
in the theater day one matate
and second depending on uh depending
again if leaks are true that baby in
Madam web is definitely p and Cinema is
back bro what do you
think uh you
know okay well I mean okay got it so we
will be there day one Venom 3 as
well um but yeah I mean you know I
haven't actually read any Venom 3 leaks
so I'm I haven't I'm Afra yeah I know
now that we' set it all loud the chat's
gonna be like well here's the whole
movie and I'm GNA be like but uh
yeah if that baby in Madam web is is
Peter then uh Cinema is going to at
least experience some disturbances or
some you know excited uh hubub I mean
they they said at the opening the
trailer meanwhile in another universe so
it's not the Sony mainstream sacred
timeline of Sony so I would be curious
to see if at the end of the movie
depending on how they handle the
inheritors or Morlin or if it's going to
be Ezekiel if Ezekiel is trying to kill
the spider totems to prevent the
inheritors from coming and that gets us
our first Spider-Man like like just
independent Sony Spider-Man that'd be
interesting absolutely o fun God so many
Spiderman c yeah so many things to do
and hope and
believe you know I think we do need the
Sony universe think they're great I
think it it serves more of a purpose
than people give it credit for thank you
John I agree Nikolai Molen thank you for
your generous uh streamlab over here oh
Alis Hodge great call Alis hod I got a
lot of love for Alis Hodge there we go
good call and I I was waiting for again
AL is so good waiting for him to come to
mind uh he is a terrific actor and he's
been holding it down for so long yes
he's like a 10 year overnight success or
20 like that guy's like oh now be no Al
but like you look at his resume he's
been killing it forever also in city on
the hill my dude Jonathan Tucker who
should also be a household name Boogie
uh good day John and Koy says Nicolai
malen uh how are you guys doing uh we're
Pleasant today this has been a fun
pretty smooth stream I think enjoyable
yeah not mad at it uh Dimitri I would
make venom have a white suit I a white
spider on his chest otherwise it's
pretty comic accurate like Todd B
farin's Venom is so funny and weird and
Tom Hardy gets that yeah uh yes sorry I
interrupted it's all good I hope to see
Pedro Pascal in Marvel at some point but
hopefully not in a controversial or bad
movie I think we can all agree about
that uh and it's a shame Kang Dynasty is
canceled was hoping to see The Avengers
and Daredevil uh have a nice day I mean
you know we could still get the Avengers
and Daredevil at some point for some
reason right also Kang Dynasty isn't
technically cancelled it just might be
within the week I mean it could be at
any time like it's just we it's just
they lost you know a writer and director
I don't know what's going on man it's a
mess I think we'll know by 2024 yes I
think the holidays are GNA they're going
to try to figure it all out January 1st
12:01 a.m. it's time to announce the Bor
Kang Dynasty that's going to be it and
uh oh hey we're at the top hey we're
gonna have to close the uh the
submission soon but not yet so you still
got a little bit of time uh the gamer MJ
have you guys
seen thank you by the way the rest of
the tomorrow verse we have not there's
three connected ones the legion
superheroes which the end leads into
Justice League War World uh and the end
of that leads into the new crisis film
there is the Doom that came to Gotham
which is love crafty and Batman as well
um yeah right now those are sort of on a
pause they they to to be quite Frank
they trailed off a little bit and uh it
became just a kind of a difficult thing
to accommodate without you know sort of
uh being at a disadvantage in the
process so um you know not to say that
they'll never come back obviously
there's definitely a possibility and
I've been certainly like Doom that came
to Gotham certainly appeared
lovecraftian that really excites me uh
and I've been kind of holding off just
you know with the the sort of Hope in
the back of my mind that maybe we can
find a way to incorporate those down the
line at some point there are no plans
for that uh you know don't get your
hopes up um but I appreciate this info
definitely going to keep note of in fact
I'm going screenshot this fure yep just
to keep note Cu uh cu hey like
regardless of of where those are at
right now you know being on pause and
whatever else uh it was such a joy and a
blast getting to watch those and I'm
anytime anyone brings them up anytime
anybody expresses joy for those uh it
makes me happy because I really really
really loved uh getting to do those to
share that with you yeah and it was a
great discovery of new stuff I didn't
know sharing stuff I knew John didn't
know like watching the Superman return
story like the return of super member I
was like I know it's going cuz love
those Comics that was really fun to to
share by way of experiencing someone
experiencing it for the first time yeah
and you know I I think I'm much more of
like a an animation head than than you
may be so um you know that too having
that inroad you know through something
that is like you know such a huge love
and passion and interest for you and
then me on the other end getting able to
learn you know from your expertise you
know through that meting it was a nicely
balanced Endeavor so I appreciate that
and gamer MJ with a followup real quick
appreciate you again double appre John
you make some valid points but to answer
your questions I've seen various films
this year and the likes of talk to me to
the Creator which is also uh in the top
five to missing uh that one was storm
Reed but I may be biased because I just
love comic book movies so much I yeah no
absolutely I was just being factious I
talk to me I really really dug I still
need to see it I I was so excited for
the rakar raka gang and I've heard good
I've heard it's you know like a a kind
of harsh watch but uh I like a harsh
watch you know and uh I'm down for it so
so yeah not not in any way to to
discredit or belittle your choice like
I'm glad that you can include the
Marvels in the top five of the year and
I can see I I can pretty easily see
through to the alternate universe where
like this is an effortlessly fun time I
got hung up on a couple just form
elements most of all uh rather than
anything they were attempting to do in
concept uh so yeah no I I I that you
loved it and I mean I'm I'm excited for
talk to me the Creator like definitely
left an impression on me and I'm glad at
least that people are you know keeping
its Spirit Alive it's not perfect movie
uh but you know and then uh Missing is
another one I'm really excited to see I
think Greg missing so and terara or Roxy
Greg and Roxy maybe did a reaction but
yeah I've heard I saw in theaters and I
was blown away I saw the first one in
theaters it was a huge surprise I just
like randomly was like you know I love
John show and then I just like walked in
I was like this movie is great and then
when missing came out I was like the
people are discovering the glory joh and
these weird like they're they're so good
joh Cho for blade for blade call it
right now joh Cho locking in in that's
right man saw I wish I could scroll back
but it's probably lost now uh oh hey no
problem uh Nikolai I I I'm glad I didn't
butcher your last name I do my best uh I
could see one of the Skarsgard actors uh
Gustaf there's a Gustaf scar scard there
are more playing Doom hold on really
quick scar what a name
there is a gustoff scars guard and I saw
his picture and my first thought was is
this guy an actor on Vikings and sure
enough this guy is an actor on look at
the picture of the three scars guards
scar there's got to be a look at all the
scars guards a weird rhyme to
encapsulate that man Bill kept busy no
stellin kept busy he's the daddy my
man's yeah has has quite the uh has
quite the the clan prolific yeah
absolutely good good tall jeans look at
all these giant scars Guardians scars
Guardians of the
Galaxy that's the the one we need I want
I want them to do like an Oceans 12
where they're just like screw it Julia
Roberts is is an in Universe character
and she's also Tess a council of scars
guys yes and they look over all of
acting um okay good okay I'm I'm finding
out where we left off here we're so
close I think we left off with fretland
uh and the the interations the rift oh
the people discovering I don't like
comedy yeah the people discovering you
had no childhood you were born in a test
tube came out like this I liked like the
generations before comedy like I'm I
like the original Animaniacs I liked
Freakazoid I liked ID I liked um the
pinky in the brain I was a big fan of
most Saturday morning cartoons like the
Batman X-Men animated series era but it
was the Next Generation I just it didn't
it didn't didn't get me and I haven't
come back you know who need we need
static shock oh we do static shock on
the case static shock and freak I I want
I don't know if I ever want liveaction
Freakazoid it could work I want more
Freakazoid in this life somehow
everybody always talks about the kid
from uh stranger things um being cast in
a in a comic movie and I'm like man that
kid is static shock which one oh Lucas
yeah I forget his name I was trying to
think like which of the white kids Finn
wolfard as static shock Finn wolfard
should have all the roles especially
stat I can't remember the actor's name
and I feel bad obviously the Lucas is
the character uh KY uh obviously you're
an idiot because his uh name is Caleb
mlin obviously that I I remembered that
of course he uh I met him at the Creed 3
uh Premier Afterparty and he was so kind
to every single kid like there was a
long line of kids that were were just so
excited to meet the guy from stranger
things and he was so patient and he like
sat down with them and just talked all
the and I was like dude this kid is big
fan of Caleb Malin is a human hey oh I'm
glad to hear that especially when we
live in a in a post Noah schnap is
always in some weird controversy world
you know who isn't Caleb ml doing good
stuff quietly not bragging about how
great he is mlin great dude uh Maria
said Maria Jose
NE I'm I'm so trying to get everyone's
name right and I and it becomes game for
me I'm like I have to Now pronounce your
name uh Lopez the scars guards and the
new Baldwins absolutely and less
controversial uh Nicholas Armstrong
Madagascar 3 is in the works keep an eye
out and uh Brian Cranston is Magneto
says Natalie Brooks it's out there but
yeah magnets
bro uh either one is both R the
polarity both of them are Magneto
anyway odil or oday Jones
thank you for joining in I believe
you're in the UK uh so bedtime I
remember character's name I forgot his
name as a person I'm so sorry I don't
see the name Caleb mclin often oh it's
but now I know it's okay Finn wolfart as
Timothy shalam as
Wonka no that's a Saturday Night Live
sketch that'll happen someday uh anyway
oday Jones after Barbie WB will want to
keep Greta Gerwig so what DC car
would you like to see her direct and or
right I say Gotham Sirens or zatana what
say you COI I would love to see her do a
zatana movie I mean you guys know from
watching the DC animat how much I love
zatana and how much I'm pulling for
zatana I think that she would get the
weird uh occult stuff that Sam Ramy
played with the Multiverse of Madness
but more in a tone that would fit the r
of Universe um really well and I think
gret Gerwig is such a fantastic director
uh Barbie's my number two movie of the
year and it would be number one won
almost any year but across the
spiderverse came out this year Barbie
was like it's in my top maybe 30 20
movies of all time like Barbie I love
Barbie was Prett so yeah I really want
gred Gerwig in the DCU and uh this Ison
to be incredible my one of my favorite
new like I I know gr gerwig's work like
I saw Little Women and stuff but but
after Barbie I'm like she's one of my
favorite like directors to watch plus
zatana all day yeah I mean I feel like Z
zatana would be my you know immediate
Cho I'm trying to think of any other
like you know I'd love to see poison IV
movie sure um character is Lush and
doesn't like a but uh it doesn't get
enough uh credit as her own character
cuz of Harley yeah yeah I I like the
idea of a character that has a bit more
like you know not like a Catwoman and
not that they even have to be like a
woman character I feel like we should
live in a world where it's not women can
direct men yeah well I don't I don't
know they don't speak the same language
joh we over this do they bring dual
lingo to set or do they have a
translator there's a translator okay
they have like a computer that got in
this case I mean Ryan Gosling was
definitely translating yeah definitely
he was translating for all of us every
line is hey girl hey girl that's how he
speaks oh real quick MJ all right Maria
I'm going to call you MJ from now on I
appreciate the clarification also love
that there is some Caleb love in the
chat and MD mum ra dwan I did not hear
that the showrunner of spectacular is
writing a miles and Peter book next year
but I bet CO's excited exited also
excited for that Ultimate Spider-Man run
yeah look out all right and uh and hey
oh someone just said they were ping out
so have a good rest of your day and8
hope that you enjoy your holidays if we
don't see you sooner um but yeah would
love to see I don't know give greet
Gerwig a Constantine side of the
Universe I don't know for whatever
reason this question made me think of
the Constantine movie City of Angels
right city of demons where you had the
like personified City lady character and
stuff and uh I have no idea why that is
on my mind here but in order to have an
interesting answer I'm going to say that
maybe that could be cool um but yeah I
would love to see a grer wig Zana most
definitely I'd also love to see her do
Booster Gold o I think she would
understand the tone very well fun koi
right very very love this choice I think
she could handle Booster Gold really
well and I'd even like it as a long form
TV show because I think they're doing it
TV but I think she would really get the
meta awareness of
booster give me that oh yeah and uh oh
hey let's see somebody in damn the mall
is a great great run over by spor at
boom Studios uh it's like very
Constantine but like just full Freedom
it's a new character damn them all um
boom Studios comic it's only on issue 10
as of this week check it out and uh good
call James MD mum again in the chat I
want a Jordan Peele DC movie Hell etran
by Jordan Peele give me the Jordan Peele
etran the bars alone are going to be
Exquisite what popular song will he take
and make a creepy piece of score into it
either way I'm into it game night
j14 thank you for being here and
contributing you guys are my favorite
reaction do on the channel thank you so
much I appreciate I feel like we haven't
done one together in a while but I uh we
brought out game night but I love o I
never seen Game Night really yeah I've
seen it damn it Coy you got my hopes up
I never lie and say I haven't seen a
thing because then if I like react too
soon I'll be like that's a lie and I
don't want the people to think because
if I if I'm reacting I'm honest
okay well it's time for some honesty
then if you could make one superhero or
villain movie who would it
be
um I would love to do a movie of Ben
Riley and I want it to be an existential
crisis about the weight of
responsibility and the villain on camera
would be Kane but the villain of the
movie would actually be about like self
self acceptance cuz I think it's really
important like we always have to punch
them up villains and I think that one of
the reasons I like w division so much
was the ship of thesis moment and I
think if we incorporate that into
Spider-Man more instead of like they
have great morals in no way home they do
a really good job with those things but
I feel like it'd be cool to see uh
Spider-Man grow up into his own
independent self through like a clone
saga story where the existential dread
of maturing is represented by the Clone
and you get to have Ben Riley represent
like the weight of trying to be too
responsible because with great power
there must also come great
responsibility but you also need to
understand you can't be responsible for
everyone so I think the Ben Riley
character he's blonde he works in a
coffee shop he's very much that like
free spirited version it'd be cool to
have him fighting a representation of of
too much responsibility and then Kane is
um you know the the the stepchild he's
the the the kicked away he's so it'd be
cool to see like those Shades uh in a
Mortal Compass story all while
Spider-Man's in college um and
Spider-Man would be basically going
through like the Harry Potter Mary Jane
Gwen Stacy era of like juggling all that
in this case if we use Tom Holland MJ
would be removed you'd have him maybe
meeting Gwen Stacy and then the love
triangle would be Felicia Hardy and I'd
have Felicia Hardy represent the freedom
of what Spider-Man can be but how that's
a slippery slope into danger and crime
and then Gwen Stacy representing the
moral compass of Science and learning
and growing so you've got these two
storylines one where it's Peter Parker
learning to grow and be his own man and
one where Spider-Man's learning to also
let himself be a person absolutely I
like I like these pictures I got a
couple small quickies uh my
uh superhero ideal movies would either
be I would love to make um a Batman a
bat in the cat story that's basically
like uh before midnight or you know
Before Sunrise Before Sunset one of
those movies where it's basically Bruce
Wayne Selena Kyle uh it starts out with
just them but then it kind of carries
onto the rooftops of Gotham into costume
and like there is you know comic book
Gotham stuff there is some crime but
that's not the main thrust of the movie
it would be like a back in and forth it
would be very much like some kind of
romantic play but with you know those
superhero flavors and Aesthetics uh no
way tonally like a joker but think of
that kind of tone shift in terms of
style that style shift uh that's always
been a dream of mine also I love Solomon
Grundy and I can imagine even though
he's always like a bit character I can
imagine doing a really cool pretty
laconic kind of movie not much dialogue
but just watching the sort of ride and
fall of this like poor Hench who gets
manipulated and then ultimately you like
is killed and then is brought back and
just sort of like do this sort of
Frankenstein esque tragedy um with sort
of little pertinent dialogue but just a
lot of body language and a lot of
atmosphere and mood uh and and really
tell this sort of somber Melancholy tale
of this monster who's just caught
between all these different people love
that um final uh Choice least flesh out
I just think Spectre is a cool character
like C gun down and comes back
supernaturally to you know intervene on
crime and the characters is never
mentioned at all in any of this DC
discourse and I want it so I'mma make it
into both those also a link later es
Xmen to be fun just a day in the mall
with Jubilee linkle men there's a
portmanto in there somewhere Brandon Jed
thank you for the contrib I'm gonna I'm
going to close off the streamlabs in
like three or the the the super chats in
like three minutes three minute warning
so so yeah you know you you can no no
pressure or anything you guys have been
super generous again really really
really appreciate all of you but you
know we do have to end this at some
point Sorry even though we don't want to
I would stay on a 10-hour live stream
with you guys um you know if I could but
we can't uh Brandon jet I love that
we're getting Sentry but I'm pretty sure
they're going to Nerf him I don't know I
mean it depends the Thunderbolts don't
seem like the most super you know all
devastating powerful yeah I feel like
Sentry might take out the Thunderbolts
and that'd be a nice change of pace for
these teamup movies if centry decimates
them I mean he would in the comics sure
okay I mean especially this team of
thunderbolts also uh someone in the chat
just went by and said uh I I don't like
comedies but have you seen gab night I
meant more comedy TV I I should have
clarified I don't rewatch a lot of
comedy movies like laughter yeah I don't
like Joy uh no I don't rewatch a lot of
com like comedy says the guy who does
comedy on stage on occasion that's true
December 2nd Flappers uh but I uh I re I
don't rewatch a lot of comedy movies and
I don't tend to watch a lot of comedy TV
um like I I I've watched Atlanta I've
watched uh the bear I've watch but like
I I generally bear is so funny it's got
comedy it sits up for comedy anyway I I
don't watch I don't re-watch a lot of
movies and I don't watch a lot of comedy
TV is what I should have said all right
all right all right all right we got it
we're clear I I I am curious to know how
they power scale I could definitely
imagine a situation in which the
character does get nerfed although
somebody pointed out that it was
conscientious of them in the Marvels to
do the the switching thing because it
does actually kind of balance the power
scale so that it's not just Captain
Marvel just coming in every 5 seconds
and just power blasting everything and
we're done um so you know I have faith
that they may be able to come up with
some kind of you know circumstance that
might
plausibly Nerf the character without too
much you know fan backlash anyway
appreciate your contribution moving on
N8 or is it Nate either way we are
grateful for you and hey Coy hey John
happy Friday happy Friday to you
appreciate everything you do and all the
free funny I like the way you put that
uh see all the Fan Expo San Francisco
attendees happy holidays uh I haven't
I'm not doing SF uh I thought I was I
know you don't love nerds I don't love
them no I mean I just found out uh but I
will be um I think doing MegaCon in
Florida so if you guys are around um I
do believe February 1st through 4th I'll
be in Florida for Megacon which is the
East Coast equivalent but I will
unfortunately not be making SF uh but it
does look stacked uh so hopefully it's
rad and send everybody on my love
especially Carl Weathers who is one of
my favorites at Carl Weathers is the
best man I'd love love sitting down with
Carl and he's going to be in SF so send
Carl my love look at this God Mark
Hamill Ewan
McGregor Elijah Hood teoa Morrison
Shatner Katie sack off tck Aston Carl
Weathers so many people Jason Lee Jason
Lee God look at all these people too
many to name we gots to move on but this
is stacked and uh and uh yeah goody good
go and report back if you're in SF for
the Expo Nate happy holiday Skyler
Hillman thank you for being here Pedro
Pascal collecting prominent roles like
Thanos Gathering bring Infinity Stones
so he can snap half of the movies ever
made out of existence and half the
episodes of the Mandalorian be real
confusing on a rewatch Coy I ended up
enjoying the Marvel's what hell yeah
secret Marvel movie in 2024 I'm so so uh
do you remember the live chat wherein I
had an ongoing beef and I was very
frustrated with someone in the chat
because they like were making examples
that felt like hyperbolically silly to
me including like sure this was that
gentleman and he uh sent me an apology
and it meant the world like it meant a
lot cuz I was like I'm so dumb for
engaging with people with diametrically
opposed views there's never going to be
a conversation well there's never going
to be a conversation on the internet
that's going to actually have anyone you
know look at either their own or the
other person's views and understand it I
was like what a what a waste of energy
and then Skyler sent me a message and I
was like hey this actually caused us
both to pause and look at our and
it means the world and then
he loved the Marvels I didn't which
means he got two better hours of his
life than I got from mine so I'm very
happy for him because I always want to
like things that I'm very happy you got
two better hours of your life than I got
of mine and that makes me so joyous so
uh hell yeah I don't think we're getting
a secret Marvel movie maybe a secret
Marvel show like they drop iron heart or
something but I don't think we're
getting a secret Marvel movie but I'm
very very stoked you love the Marvel
Skyler absolutely and with that gang we
are closing down perfect last one to
shut it down Super Chat submissions
we're going to read the rest of them
don't wor going anywhere and I love that
when you choose to do this YouTube gives
you this warning it's like are you sure
you want it do you understand the
implications implications you have to
check the box understanding the
implications all right we're popped off
but we are going to complete what we've
got here honor got we got 25 odd minutes
left on this stream here so we're going
to make the most of each
minuto space titties it's my favorite
name of the day what's your thoughts
thank you for being here and gracing us
with your voluptuousness uh what's your
thoughts on Pedra Pascal's casting
rather than the
cin uh I think it's more interesting uh
you know I thought he was fine in
Multiverse Madness uh I'm sure it would
have been good but ultimately I am more
excited by a choice that's less you know
like the one everybody wanted I
guess so I don't know uh I think it's I
don't know It's tricky
because the the krinski thing was always
just a moment it was never meant to be
the read and and I think that it's the
the fact that people are saying wait I
thought John krinski was Reed Richards
kind of proves my point about variance
not working in movies versus Comics like
there's a different mindset like variant
and comic books are a different artist a
different incor a different writer or
just like a comic is like well I'm not
attached to this actor that's a drawing
of a character whereas in a movie you're
G to go like oh that's not our Downey
Junior we lived with for 15 years as
Iron Man that's a different one from
Another Earth you're not you're going to
go like there he is like if people think
kosinski's Reed that kind of proves my
point that people think that's Reed so
um I always thought it was understood to
be a variant um but more and more as the
casting happens most of my comments when
I post about it are like that was John
krinski uh I am conflicted because that
does show that it's going to be a messy
conclusion of this Multiverse Arc
because of the language of comics but um
I I don't know what else they could do
uh I I don't know about Pedro we're
gonna have to
see lovely that was an answer that was a
conscientious answer Koy I appreciate it
and uh and good we I like the people are
already preemptively leaving me name
pronunciations in the chat good on you
guys got to get everyone represented
properly Nick
Alexander uh here's a guy with the
automobile dealership right Nick can't
say no anyway thank you for being here
and contributing to the chat love you
guys and the streams excited to watch
later COI fellow Bostonian yeah real
quick what's your favorite Boston based
hero
o that's not easy I know what mine is I
don't think he's Boston based but his
name is Boston oh I was yeah well that's
that's not he's not like named after the
city I mean de is great named after de
is great uh I mean Captain Marvel comes
to mind quickly iron har went to
MIT um but favorite man um it's hard I'm
actually like drawing a blank on others
right now now let me let me let me think
let me be sure let me be sure I'm not
missing I want to say Kyle renner's from
Boston but I think that's wrong do it
hey just make it up right now I don't
want to lie to the people and uh my
favorite Muppet man that's that's a hard
one cuz there's so many Muppet things I
still have to see in this life uh I
think you know animal is probably the
one that matches me the best I animal I
am probably animal I mean you know you
got to love a Kermit uh you know Gonzo
is real fun Cookie Monster makes me
laugh just because he's so you know
monosyllabic about things or well I
guess cookie is a two syllable word I do
love dum dum Dugan dum dum Duan you have
a list here of all the Boston Heroes I'm
glad somebody compiled it though it's
very efficient it's good it's I'm gonna
I'm gonna lock it down I'm gonna confirm
all right also I think Captain Marvel's
technically from Main uh oh Stephen King
Emma Frost Emma Frost Emma Frost
favorite Boston based character good
pick Koy Mr ET thank you for being here
uh jav Javier bardam rumored to be in
talks for galatis but I want Doom first
and I want Anthony star to play Doom
Anthony star Anthony star apologies to
anony in chat uh no I I repeated it and
it's a guys names uh anony star uh would
be a really fun pick um he's got that
Cheshire grin that's so like malicious
um but I do feel like that's very like
linear casting that's very like well
that makes sense um man he's fun but I I
think that galatis suits they're already
going to have an established fantastic
forward and already have an established
Doom in the world so I think he might be
in the movie but I think a big bad like
Silver Surfer and Galactus is more
Cosmic and it's more like the scope of
making the Fantastic 4 feel different so
I understand where you're coming from
but I think the version of FF they're
going to bring in galatis will suit
groovy all right uh we we're gonna have
to kind of start powering through
raccoon shampoo back in Action thank you
so much for being here I'm conflicted on
them bringing the fox versions and cast
of the X-Men into the MCU even if it's
not permanent like will it feel awkward
if they introduce their own X-Men after
everyone has already met the fox X-Men
not when they die not when they die and
not when they choose which ones to keep
on hand I think we're going to get a
bunch uh bite it in Deadpool and then I
think we're going to get all of them
bite it in the beautiful fond Fairland
Secret Wars to allow us to bring in the
new one I'm excited for that most deaf
uh Bucky Barnes appreciate you holding
it down in the chat for so many chats as
well uh so many of these live streams
happy holidays and I appre appreciate
you guys we appreciate you everybody in
the chat send some love Bucky barnes's
way Bucky Barnes has been a staple of
these live streams for a good amount of
time now and uh we couldn't do it
without you so we appreciate you very
much uh milky death thank you for
joining in I have been saying Javier
bardam for Doom for years now uh now
they're talking to him about galatis
when they need a doom come on but I feel
like and we've talked a lot about doom
and we just talked about you know a
little bit of galatis 2
in my you know limited perspective
Javier bardam actually sounds more apt
to play a galatis than I don't know I
feel like Doom I imagine a different
stature and for what they're doing here
a bit of a younger actor where as like
galatis I don't see that as being as
important or tied to 10 years of like I
mean or just you know it's a voice um my
you know galatis is obvious yes Michael
Shannon Michael Sheen it's perfect uh
but I I do think uh jav then a few years
ago might have worked for a long running
character I just don't know if he'd want
to commit for 10 years absolutely Fair
concern extreme Viper 99 thank you for
joining in and hey thank you hey guys
for Super Chat longtime listener first
time caller thank you for jumping in for
for uh I'm not going to use that turn of
phrase for uh you know pulling that
Band-Aid off with us huge fan of ko
rants yeah been nice today I promised
yeah you think the Disney Plus shows are
in different universes example moonight
not in the sacred timeline I do I do
very much I think we're going to find
out in secret Wars and maybe depending
on if Kang Dynasty happens that the
universes we've been living through are
not all the same one so I do very much
believe that we will have uh an
experience where we're going to realize
that characters haven't met and they get
folded into each other and meet each
other I think that's how She-Hulk can
break the fourth wall a bit I think
that's how moonight happening in the way
it has I I do think they're in different
universes yes absolute vodka good good
good all right let's get back on to
where we were sorry just did one more
refresh uh golly we do have to uh do a
lightning round here okay okay yeah so
where are we at where we at no goodness
gracious you guys have been so generous
today too um all right let's see let's
see let's see we
scrolling uh okay there we go we gotcha
all right let's get these back up on
screen and uh Angel Bautista thank you
for joining in the chat um super chats
there we go yeah cool uh is Deadpool 3
the connector to all the Multiverse
jumps with Spider-Man the Marvel shanqi
Etc I believe so I think it's not only
going to end the fox universe or start
the path that ends the fox universe but
is also the great connector because he
is a fourth ball breaking allseeing
omnipresence or not to that level but
yes I think he's going to be very
integral to uh connecting everything
coming this July Zia good answer Coy I
appreciate that dead shot what are we
some kind of Super Chat Squad thank you
for being here hey guys want to know
your thoughts on Steven young playing
Century we have we have trotten that
ground uh quite a bit you know I'm a
little bit more familiar I'm looking
forward to it koi a little less familiar
with his chops uh going to have to play
two sides of a personality two sides of
a power set but uh you know at least
cautiously optimistic some people seem
to be upset about it but I don't see it
as a drastic change I mean uh he's a b B
jacked Fabio looking guy visually a very
big change stepen young seems like a
more slight man doesn't quite like live
in the gym like Fabio um but uh steroids
maybe get some steroids get some some
flowing locks and then we'll see I think
acting is is more important but we'll
see what happens absolutely I love
acting too uh Hey King Tut ramma Tut
thanks for joining the chat all the way
across the Multiverse if Pedro Pascal is
officially castes Reed Richards What
actors could you see having great
chemistry with him playing the roles of
the first family
I mean we've got some pretty strong
rumors but hey throw out and for years
yes and they haven't really shifted that
much well kind of a little bit but yeah
uh I'll do one variant of each uh H
Mallen Le is thing yes I want it forever
uh um I want um man Emily Blunt would
have been a good Sue but it's just too
easy I'm gonna do a better one I'm gonna
do a different one that way it's not
just the easy choices all around uh I
think oh you got good better be good I
would to be good I I have Zack Efron's
too easy Emily bl's too easy Glenn pow
is Johnny Storm want Glen Po in DC more
than Marvel which is funny Fair
um okay Human Torch I'mma
go five four three Barry keone Human
Torch Killian Murphy Dr Tom good uh uh
Kerrie Condon Su storm groovy and um and
the donkey from banshees of inish here
uh and and and Colin Ferell is thing for
an all Irish fantastic beautiful the
first the first family the first family
of Dublin dream boy thank you for being
here thank you for enchanting our dreams
and rip my dreams of Andrew Linkin uh
from Reed Richards for Reed Richards as
Reed Richards from The Walking Dead from
Love Actually and other things that are
overshadowed by those two properties it
doesn't seem like it's it's fully fully
totally in so wait to wait to rip those
dreams yeah also someone in the chat
said bill is the thing and it is
clober in time I love it I am about that
I can hear him throwing that line was
it's clobbering time also old dad's dude
old dad's in Netflix is so funny I got
to see that's a comedy I may actually
rewatch the next five to 10 Monumental
day hold out on those hopes for Andrew
Lincoln he could still pop up Robo 96
thank you for joining in the chat do you
think the way Marvel is right now
starring in an MCU project is stay on an
actor's filmography I no I don't think
so I I mean it is the the thing that I
don't know it seems like a fun enough
assignment for everybody and I feel like
if any of these guys you know these
these thespian actors especially that
they pull in for these things like they
will be able to go off and do any amount
of slightly less budgeted or independent
fair that they want to do and I don't
think it I unless it's a situation like
a Jonathan major where there's like a
whole bunch of other stuff that doesn't
even relate to this that's affecting it
I just doubt like unless you come in and
just do a really bad job or something I
don't think it's yeah I think it's like
a way to get to be a household name and
then you get more leverage to do the
films that you are if you're like an art
housee actor then you can make movies
happen easier it's getting a budget for
movie is not easy and if you're more of
a household name it allows you to make
more work so I think it's a net positive
Fring actor g g Richie Brash thank you
so much for being here and joining in I
am really disappointed that Adam driver
isn't going to be Reed thought he would
have been perfect what Young individual
will Pedro be protecting in fantastic
for uh his kids uh I I imagine at least
Franklin Richards is in there I think
they're going to have Marvel's first
family be fully fledged a family with
their kids I know what they're going to
do they're going to put Jonathan maor's
head on like a baby body like that movie
with Marlon way and that's going to be
Nathaniel Richards right there that's
going to be he's going to have him in
like one of those little baby babyj baby
be but it's going to be his own long
arms wrapped around yes that's how it's
done you heard it here first leaks it's
all confirmed Rick alt thank you for
being here thank you for the very
generous contribution my fan cast for
Reed has always been Brandon Ruth
Superman uh returns Fame ever since I
saw him in DC Legends of tomorrow he's
been my dream Mr Fantastic though I
don't know if he'd want to play another
superhero now uh you know I I don't know
if I would necessarily be like gleeful
but I I'm always kind of rooting for
Brandon Ralph I liked him as Superman
more than people give him credit for I
think he's a delight he's also a nerd
like he actually enjoys cons and and
every time uh you know anytime I've
talked to him about comic stuff he's way
more in the no than a lot of folk like
he actually is pretty plugged into the
nerd space so I think he's he's just
wonderful then give me ralth I changed
my mind I wanted to play the whole
fantastic lucky BX thank you for being
here and uh I why Josh Dell is not
considered for Mr Fantastic he's a good
actor and he resembles the character
I've often wondered like Alex Ross
definitely paints after some actors and
I've of wonder if there's ever a casting
person that's like let's just look at
the people that like the people have
been painting them like and Josh Josh
Dell definitely has that Vibe um I just
yeah I don't know if he's interested but
I I thought that was funny because he
definitely looks like some fantastic for
Alex Ross covers good call GE also
loving the Bucky Barnes love in the chat
keep holding it down my dude uh Sidra Zi
uh I have mixed feelings for Madam Webb
movie I don't know if it's cuz it's a
Sony movie but something feels off it's
a quirky tra like everything that comes
out of the so the spunk is is quirky and
and
whooshy a l not making choices uh but I
got to say yeah that 2000's Cannon blast
of just of of Madness it it is exciting
in a whole other way cuz you know I
don't know I feel like a Marvel or a DC
trailer DC is about to be reset but you
know you kind of have an expectation of
tone whereas like whenever we get a Sony
I'm like I don't know who knows what
might happen what we're going to get I
just know it makes me want to put on
some junko jeans and it makes me want to
stroll into that theater with my Walkman
listening to slip knot maybe some
Evanescence and that is what I want to
feel wake me up Lane Copeland thank you
for joining in at least the street level
of the MCU is looking super promising at
the moment can't wait for the Derek
devil Spidey stuff looking forward I
mean you know Echo looking surprisingly
good Kingpin looking surprisingly harsh
more Netflix esque in that trailer
certainly a good move uh and yeah I mean
where we left Peter off you know going
back to the more original the more DIY
uh you know I feel like Spidey and
Daredevil teaming up is maybe a little
still down the line but I'm looking
forward to it daredevil show hopefully
turns out good when they figure out what
they're doing with it so yeah yeah I I'm
I lean more street level in the comic
stuff so I'm always excited when the
street level stuff gets announced Boogie
Johnny thank you for joining in real
quick for both of you favorite movie
this year across spiderverse oh boy it's
going to be sawx when I finally see it
yep yep for sure that's that's what
it'll be uh I'll have to think oh
goodness what yeah um I don't know
Barbie Oppenheimer like they're all up
there yeah um for the Sony uner I I'll
think on that it's always the hardest to
choose a fave right um for the Sony
Universe do you think they're doing a
reverse of what the MCU did this is Rick
alt again and thank you each of these
has been super generous I really
appreciate that for the Sony Universe do
you think they're doing a reverse of
what the MCU did where instead of having
Heroes leading up to fighting a villain
they're going to do villains leading up
to fighting the hero Spider-Man I think
that is a cool uh Theory I have been
wanting for years them to do a Sinister
Six that was like oceans where you get
to meet all the criminals and they're
like endearing and they're they you're
drawn to them so I think having villain
movies um especially if you can have the
characters be likable like Aaron Taylor
Johnson he's hunting poachers he's still
killing but he's killing you know
I think that's the move and I
think a Sinister 6 movie with characters
you're actually invested in like how fun
Tom Hardy's Venom is ETC would be a way
to make it fun to have them fight Spidey
yes groovy Grand rure thank you for
joining in think we'll see Loki and Thor
five brothers team
up I don't I I would be torn uh I I feel
like Thor five might be a little soon
for that but also like you know if it's
going to be like the last Hemsworth you
know I might want some kind of Brothers
team up so I don't know yeah I I if
they're going to do Loki they got to
make sure it's the right tone the right
director I don't want him to come back I
love where
we're already bringing Logan back after
Logan so we got to be careful tread
lightly but yeah I mean like spiritually
I would love a Brother's team up again
especially with the growth that Loki's
been through and seeing how Thor reacts
to all of that that would be very
interesting to me uh Deadshot thank you
for joining in once again I was
introduced to the Marvel Zombies when I
found the comic in high school school
library that's a cool ass School somehow
and I love the comic series very excited
for the show uh yeah I mean you know we
I thought the was okay I understand that
the zombies are Port I I like what I
understand about the zombie portrayal in
the comics a bit more than how they did
in the show so uh I'm I'm curious and
and consciously optimistic about the
show but I am also sort of going in with
that taste from the wh if as my main
Touchstone for what it would be like
also check your local library for Comics
they often carry them and if they don't
physically have them you can often
request trade paperback so Comics are
are a lot more accessible than people
think and if you like them then support
a local comic store but you can get a
Gateway at your library some of my
Greg's formative comic book experiences
were through the library absolutely back
in the day extreme Viper 99 thank you so
much uh best live action Miles Morales
go a 14-year-old kid that I don't know
like I I want him to be young you know
what I mean like I I really like I don't
know a lot of 14-year-old actors
everyone I know Caleb mlin Caleb mlin
you know by the time they film season
five of stranger things that that that
guy's gonna have a mortgage care if he
does already care but yeah I want I want
someone like 14 I want I want like a
young it doesn't have to be an unknown
but one of the new Ninja Turtles yeah
mayem that kid from Haunted management
was great sure go for that Tom uh Skyler
Hillman Tom Kavanagh as Doom I haven't
watched a lot of flash uh my friend Jess
was on it for a season so I went and
visited set a lot and Tom Kavanagh was
very nice um he he causes Mischief on
set and plays the bouncy ball sometimes
during takes which is very funny but uh
beautiful I don't know his work enough
to comment I just know the man is a
delight absolutely extreme Viper back in
appreciate you don't want Infinity War
copied with the Avengers losing just to
win again how would you lead Kang
Dynasty into Secret Wars without that uh
I would have them uh defeated by Kang
and have Kang be defeated by doom and
have Doom be the ultimate power that
we've never dealt with before building
battle world and requiring heroes from
all different multiverses to team up to
take them out causing the need for the
multiversal stuff in Deadpool are about
to get to turn into a positive as
opposed to a negative and then the
ultimate sacrifice of a hero Allah
heroes are born in 1990 something series
uh to sacrifice themselves to save one
through line thus ultimately they're not
being a winner because we lose heroes in
the process of saving the day groov V uh
Rick alt thank you so much for the
generous contribution I'm really looking
forward to Craven he's my favorite
villain and I hope they do him right for
the movies coin comic recommendations
for Craven besides last hunt I already
read that one and it was beautiful uh
there is a sequel to Craven's last hunt
called the Grim hunt which is shockingly
good considering um it is you know a
sequel to one of the best ever or it's
called hunted the two ones I want going
to read are called hunted and the Grim
hunt I'm forgetting which one's which
right now I think it's hunted is the
sequel Grim Hunt is also exceptional and
very ethereal um and then I would say um
I'm a big fan of Torment the Todd
McFarlan Craven stuff from
1990 and 91 those are both exceptional I
literally made a Tik Tok uh like four
days ago about craving comic recx so
check out my Tik Tok for all sorts of
comic rexs in general I try to do like
one or two a week of what to read if you
like this character also MJ in the chat
is a librarian yeah go visit your local
library shouts out to Librarians
everywhere especially you my dear thanks
for holding it down and for being such a
lovely presence in the chat today big
Library guy big fan lucky BX why uh
thank you for being here my what the
fudge moment with the Marvels is why did
Carol have the other Quantum band on at
the end of the movie and not Camala uh I
think she gave it to her but they didn't
have any scene or any sort of yeah they
didn't give it any reason and that would
have been nice and also any sort of you
know I got problems with marbles they
didn't say they didn't say yeah I I'm
going with the friendship bracelet thing
because I think Cala would do that and
apparently it doesn't seem like she
really needs the B somehow I wish that
explained that too AJ what are you
talking about AJ Bristol Thunderbolts
thank you for being here brother and
thank you for jumping in or whoever you
are AJ could be any set of names uh
Thunderbolts in the movie we find out
Doom is the one pulling the strings pull
the string uh the Young Avengers and
Thunderbolts try to stop Doom but fail
all while reality is breaking more and
more in the
6161 1999999 this is kind of like what
you were saying before I think you're on
a similar wavelength similar page
absolutely and that's fun yeah I think
we're going to be finding all of that
happening and uh I think we're thinking
similarly when Koy gets hired at Marvel
you will be his his assistant I'll be
reach now dead shot back in the chat
thank you so much imagine Kang Dynasty
involved doom and he teams up with the
heroes but in the end he kills Kang the
way he kills Thanos holding his spine
and skull in the end created battle
World leading to uh Secret Wars uh SW I
always have to calibrate my mind I'm
like are we talking sex work Star Wars
or something else there's a lot of SWS
out in the game uh you know I I really
think that was their original plan maybe
not the the graphic uh rated violence
because I don't think PG-13 would allow
for the skull but uh maybe uh but yeah I
I think that's what they were going to
do and a bummer if that doesn't get to
happen absolutely uh masar Riz
appreciate you joining in two quick
things and we got to keep it quick but
appreciate you here love you guys and
Greg keep up all the good work and
positive vibes we do our best that's
that's the believe it or not that's Theo
around here and two koi going off on all
the haters last stream really made my
day I'm glad I didn't have to today I'm
glad it's been chill I needed the rest
absolutely but you know we all love a
good koi rant I feel you raccoon shampoo
thank you once again for joining in
after Peacemaker and Andor I'm excited
for Ekko and that Agatha Harkness show
whatever they're calling it this month
they have changed that quite a few times
it always seems to be the who asked for
the shows that turn out well and I think
that makes sense cuz I think they're
under a little less pressure in a way I
think the who asked for this are often
Freer to go do their own thing a little
bit and not have to worry about bigger
stakes and and people complaining it
wasn't what they imagine that's the
hardest part about making a comic into a
movie is it's a director an actor a
writer all these different visions and
if it's not what you thought was people
get mad and that's not fair so a lesser
known property has more flexibility
because you're not assuming a lot
absolutely masar Riz back in appreciates
you also has koi seen Arcane if not I
already know he will fall in love with
it but knowing my luck he probably has
and didn't like it I couldn't get into
it oh Koy I tried it wasn't for me Koy
I'm going to kill you after this I'm
sorry I'm going to murder you in Glad
people love it I'm so glad people love
it friends of mine worked on it just not
just not it's not for me it's okay it's
okay so sorry Mason Frost we love you
you we appreciate you I think that Rudy
panko as Johnny Storm would be on the
same level of perfect as Ebon for the
thing his character in Outer Banks is
literally Johnny I don't know Rudy panko
but he's got a cool name he does have a
cool name up quickly Rudy pank with the
speed Rudy that's the
uh oh he looks like a he looks like a
Johnny Storm for SE guy I've seen this
guy okay big Johnny Storm Vibes he was
in Uncharted the best video game oh I
talked to him at the no way home
Premiere he was really nice perf there's
a photo of him I was like wait I've seen
that man oh wait I was literally at that
moment sounds nice yeah yeah you were
there elm and I must have not have maybe
talked to him too I don't know I was
there I was there somewhere elmet thank
you so much for jumping in I want to see
Ben Grim to be visibly Jewish even if
for a short scene I need my Jewish
Heroes to represent more than just
saying mlov once hugs agree Coy do you
agree uh yeah I think anytime you know
the MC Jews need to show up that's
what's going to be the newest problem
people have with anything uh yeah I
think that anytime a culture is a a big
part of a character it's really
wonderful to see people that identify
with that culture getting someone that
they can latch on to and like feel for
like I I cannot even explain how you
know I'm I'm not even like from Ireland
Irish I'm like my great great
grandparents from Ireland but hearing
Barry in eternals meant so much to me
because of how much I like love Irish
culture and whenever I visit Ireland I
feel connected so uh yeah I I want that
for people to have that in their
character
absolutely all right we're going to have
to go super super lightning with this
because we still got a few of these left
uh what we Super Chat okay cool cool
cool cool uh Garfield's Bizarre
Adventure Marvel is destroying its brand
with these constant re-shoot that's
overworking the VFX team ballooning
their budgets $250 million budgets too
much and uh I agree with you yeah I
agree I think uh the modular way they
shoot these things doesn't workmore yeah
and didn't work before but they were
making enough money that it didn't have
to not work yeah and it just seems like
they're already spend spending so much
time and resource on things that might
just get junked and reworked entirely
and I I yeah I don't think it helps the
storytelling or the overall success of
the franchise in particular so yeah I
think this phase we've gone way too far
down that path and we should reain it in
seconds from disaster thank you so much
for being here they need to do a solo
Doom movie to flesh out his backstory I
feel the MCU will nerf and underutilize
doom and make him feel rushed I don't
think they have time to make a full
flight Doom movie with their schedule
and that's one of the reasons you
shouldn't map out things so far because
it does undermine the ability to make
things on the Fly that you might need
yeah Zari srino Jr picture this Council
of reads Pascal is 616 re cinski
Griffith teller show up from F4 uh I
think that Kang Dynasty happens recast
or not uh I think I Council reads be a
lot of fun and maybe that's why we were
hearing all the rumors Winston over
capes and CS had a good idea that like
maybe Jake does play him but that would
be confusing because of Mysterio and
whatnot but like you have all the rumors
as a read I do think it's a bit of a
hard sell to an audience just
discovering rude Richards but maybe it
would work because we did have krinski
absolutely and uh and hey here's hoping
that they still find a way to do their
Kang Dynasty and don't have to rewrite
everything Michael Walters how do y'all
feel about the title of the Avengers 5
being called Avengers Siege at Castle
doom and Kings Blended The Siege story
line leading into Secret Wars love the
channel uh The Siege St line was very
popular for a reason I don't know if
they'll go that way in the movies to
introduce him but it would be a fun way
to start into that and I think that
following the framework of a successful
comic is smart we'll see absolutely
Michelle thank you so much if you could
play any P future MCU character who
would it be uh if you could play any
Pastor future MCU character would it be
uh I've always always always wanted to
play either Johnny Storm or Carnage uh I
think both would be a lot of fun and
both have been up here for a long time
or Flash Thompson actually went out for
Flash in the Andrew Garfield there Loki
gmass 2005 be a good Loki thanks man uh
what directors would you guys want to
see directing Secret Wars coming off
Loki I honestly think your boys Aaron
Morehead and Justin Benson would do an
amazing job I agree with that couldn't
be more biased but yes yep yep Justin
and Aaron just give them everything give
them whatever they want that's always
what the internet says and it's never
never too much no they don't need sleep
they need make art we got uh we got
Galla ghost in here onr how you doing
brother love you uh hey gentlemen been a
while since I caught a live stream
sending you love from Boston yeah I'm
jealous friend enjoy it there breathe it
in for me love you get that Dunkin Donut
air yeah kid James Jennings when and how
do you think the MCU will show us that
they've we've been watching the
Multiverse for a long time and who's in
that in what Multiverse together in what
universe together I think we'll get that
sense pretty soon probably even with
like a Deadpool 3 yeah I think either
Deadpool 3 or Kang dynast or whatever
secret War one is going to be is going
to spell that all out for us absolutely
looks like it gala ghost again John love
your choices for the filmfest based on
the letters of your first name if you
could uh do a stream of your favorite
movies here what did you pick o uh I
mean some of my favorite movies would Ed
Wood is my favorite movie uh I love a
lot of horror stuff like the thing and
uh Texas Chainsaw Massacre not the
Living Dead I love the before Trilogy
and things like that I guess those would
be movies that I would be inclined to
like chill and chat about so uh so
that's kind of what comes to mind but uh
I loved that prompt that like it's do a
film festival uh with the acronym of
your name basically so like a j movie
and O movie and H movie and an N movie
so I did Jumanji Oh Brother Where Art
Thou hack and Napoleon Dynamite and I
think that a perfect Film Festival gala
ghost Koy you just found out that your
all-time favorite movie is Fight Club uh
just found out that your alltime
favorite movies is Fight Club I haven't
seen it yet reaction at some point my
number two can you it's always GNA cause
that reaction can you just wax poetic
about why it's your favorite uh movie of
all time please you got 20 seconds
briefly briefly waxing poetic I think
it's a beautiful litmus test for people
if you think Tyler Duran is the
protagonist you and I are probably going
to have dising views uh but if you see
as an antagonist and you you are able to
Define what you are as a man like I love
that it's a movie about masculine energy
that really tells you a lot about the
man watching it and I love that a movie
that has important messages for men is
able to be so popular and that also a
lot of people misinterpret it I think
it's perfectly shot perfectly written
perfectly edited I think it's a rare
Perfect movie as far as all of its
pieces and it is literally the coolest
character but if you're trying to be
cool and if you're doing things that
harm others that negates a lot of things
and I think it really shows who you are
as a person by how you interpret Tyler
Jordan G Matt uh robertt F I caught you
earlier Matt Barry Matt Barry is Doom
what do y'all think I couldn't think of
a better choice uh you know these should
be line readings alone oh yes please and
thank you uh Lloyd 10 plus thank you for
joining in I'm a firm believer that my
baby girl Wanda is still alive I am too
I'm hoping that we find her having slip
to the X-Men Universe where Monica is
now I agree I think we're going to see a
lot more Wanda uh if if if if Lizzy
wants to come back as the character I
think they gave her an out with that
death but I think it ended that
character but she's definitely not gone
and I know my pants are Scottish they're
good Scottish pants I see you chat
Boogie Lloyd templos also by the way
freaking love you guys love you too
appreciate you much rock and roll Energy
Grand rakor what do you think of Killian
Murphy for Doom Coy named him as a fan
cast I like the Irish casting of
Fantastic 4 I think he's a little small
on the physical side so you'd need to
cast someone else as the body because
he's like five seven but otherwise
lovely masquer is thank you if you were
both made head of DC creative what would
your first respective projects
be uh Mr Miracle because otherwise
I don't think it'll ever get made and I
think that story is very important to
modern pop culture and a very unique
tale that only DC could really tell all
right I'm gonna do like a weird rashell
ghoul origin movie zatana is my second
green light though both of ours we're
going to team up for zatana we're
teaming up for zatana and that kicks off
the new youu Quenton based off How uh
Amazing Spider-Man 2 was what do you
think or what do you want insomniac's
Wolverine to be about oh golly I am not
the Gamer In The Crowd uh I guess I
would just want I don't know the
Spider-Man games just have such a deeply
uh you know Rich storytelling it seems
like combined with I don't know what
would equate to like the magic of The
Swinging I've heard you know people
constantly talking Berserker rage where
you get into a flow and it'd be really
cool to have like the my main focus is
gonna be on the fight um
uh what what do they call it when you
mechanics fight mechanics are goingon to
be the the swing mechanics I think
Wolverine Boogie Heather gear love you
thank you for joining in the chat as
well good to see you good to hear from
you sending Good Vibes for the weekend
love you guys love you too appreciate
you very much and uh jumping over for
the patreon as well uh Rick alt thank
you so much for uh jumping in again Coy
any comic book recommendations for kid
Nova he's become one of my favorite
Heroes since I saw him in the Ultimate
Spider-Man show and I want to learn more
about him also do you think we'll see
him in the MCU before or after secret
War I think we'll see him probably in
secret Wars I think we're going to
introduce a new few characters they're
going to bring into the new era of
Marvel I think Nova is going to be one
of those because they've teased them for
so long but I don't think there's a
property that's going to fit them before
them but I think you should read the
current Nova run well it just ended but
like 2019 had a Nova run that featured
kid Nova and he's also a really cool
character in Champions pick up Champions
issue one that came out in like 2018
2019 by Mark Wade that'll be a really
good over run for you to get to to get
to the modern day awesome awesome
awesome and hey Mr ET Rufus in dark city
is fantastic true that underrated movie
go check it out JP what hope do we have
for Rebel Moon knowing SNY has bad
history with his World building and
storytelling C man of Ste Obama v
Superman just League Sucker Punch um
cautiously optimistic I you know yeah
Zack Snyder uh makes these very like you
know heavy rot things and uh I often
tend to at least enjoy some aspect of
them I'm just waiting to see if this is
one of the ones that you know
particularly grabs me I could see it
going either way uh I think a Star Wars
es Universe does a lot of the
storytelling for him and I think the
visuals look fantastic fantastic and I'm
really excited for Rebel Moon because
I'm excited he gets to play in his own
sandbox instead of playing with IP that
other people have associations with boom
raccoon shampoo do you guys have any
thoughts on or plans to cover the new
Percy Jackson adaptation uh maybe not
sure about coverage it's possible since
it is a prominent property um we'll see
haven't read the books haven't seen the
movies so I don't have any opinions
about oh I haven't seen them either
let's watch Percy Jackson watch pery
Jackson Percy Jackson I don't have any
connotation so yeah let's watch Percy
Jackson boom we got excitement at the
very least Deadshot Fishburn would have
an amazing Dr Doom I agree with you uh
but you know too bad he's already
Goliath or whatever that guy's name is
who shown up in what of season 2 looks
like and yeah look out gr rakor follow
up to my list if not kiling Murphy is
Doom is there an MCU character you'd
like to see him as thoughts on
Oppenheimer it blew me away pun intended
uh Oppenheimer terrific did a whole
review on it loved him uh pretty much
loved the movie and uh yeah who else
real quick in the real quick I think
it'd be really cool to do a uh
Generation X movie where Emma Frost and
Banshee are the uh leaders of the school
and he'd be an incredible Banshee boom
raccoon shampoo if Kang Dynasty is
scrapped will they replace it with a
different Avengers movie or will we just
skip straight to Secret Wars uh I think
they'll do a secret Wars part one and
part two they'll probably name it
something else but it'll effectively
feel like a two-part Secret Wars movie
boom uh Mas Riz I'd like to recommend a
YouTube channel to you guys I'm going to
screenshot this then uh Georgia da she's
a licensed therapist who likes all the
nerd stuff we do and she's able to
psychoanalyze the characters it's so
unique I love a good expert reacts love
that very much cool idea absolutely
legal eagle apparently not a laer for
SSS sniper I learned that two weeks ago
in a live stream oh God uh Bucky Barnes
smash the like button like Co smashes
weights you are a swole nerd and I
appreciate you for it uh Joe o'keef keep
the faith Brothers in love appreciate
you keeping the love alive and uh thank
you for helping us do that all the way
out in the Europe Rick Al last question
since Thanksgiving is coming up what are
your top three favorite foods to eat on
Thanksgiving minor stuff and mashed
potatoes and deviled eggs love you guys
I hope you have a good
day I like um a good I mean a mashed
potato is your is your classic starch um
I'm going to go I'm going to go off the
beaten path I'm going to say uh we make
like a homemade biscuit every year that
I kind of look forward to to accompany
everything um I like the the I don't
know I feel like all my choices are
going to be kind of shitty uh stuffing
but the cheap stuff if you make homemade
stuffing I don't trust you I want stove
top I want soggy bread I want broth in
my stuffing that's it uh mashed potatoes
obviously like they're the best and
pecan pie PE pie the gravy and the mash
let's do this shouts out to a good green
bean autr as well hope you all have a
good Thanksgiving when it comes uh
Stephanie Horton thank you and goodbye
hope you had a good stream if you're
seeing this still thank you for the
sticker Dart car oh my God are we we've
done it we've done it Dart car why did
Aunt Ma die if Uncle Ben already did uh
because everyone dies and every your
parents are both going to die so prepare
for that cuz every because life is short
everybody
dies you learn you learn new lessons
from each death just like you learn new
lessons from each birth and each
marriage and each relationship you ever
have they all have different lessons to
teach you and appreciate every
relationship you had because it's going
to end and as will you all right gang we
are going to do one final refresher just
to make sure we are all caught up but
seriously thank you so much for being
here for contributing for supporting the
channel we got a couple couple couple
stragglers here that we're going to read
off for the very very end and then we
are out Audi A4 my friend and it looks
like yes we are done with the super
chats to the last of the streamlabs and
then we're getting out of here thank you
guys seriously for being here we
couldn't do this without your just you
know love and attention uh for lack of a
better more humble way of phrasing that
NE n n
nadak
reog uh first just want to say I love
y'all like Pim loves ants I love uh I
have a theory that Kang uh the Kang that
died in Ant-Man is just stuck in a
probability storm like Ant-Man was and
his probabilities will fight each other
in the last one standing becomes Kang
Prime I like that theory I love that
theory and also the ability of maybe in
that time where he's stuck he gains more
power un thus he becomes able to conquer
time and that's how he gets out of the
probability storm I think that was one
of the ideas originally but I don't know
if that's ever going to happen now
beautiful uh Seth ARP taking us home to
parter here uh thank you so much I'd
love to hear your thoughts on who should
be the next three to five main villains
for the MCU post gang doom and Galactic
are already coming down the pike in the
midst of Kang's Reign so who do you
think will go uh who do you go to top
that and raise the universal multiversal
Stakes also if and when the MCU ever
does officially end who's your final
villain or maybe is there a previous
villain you'd bring back with a new
Mission or motivation he wants to start
a paper uh this is an essay I think that
if the MCU does end it'll end in a
reboot I think they will be doing that
with Secret Wars I think that basically
they're allowing themselves to re redo
everything and they're going to be
focused more on the Xmen and the
Fantastic Four so I think Doom is going
to be a great carryover as one of the
main villains I think that uh we're
going to see more original villains of
the X-Men we haven't seen before like
Omega Red I think we might see fun stuff
like arcade I think we might see crazy
stuff like you know galatis but I think
it's going to be leaning towards those
Fox characters for a little bit because
I do think that's going to be new and
original I think that answers most of
those one broad sweep yeah yeah all
right good Coy you did it we did it yeah
I was going to say we did it you squeez
some some potential future villains in
there I think man all right guys thank
you this has been a marathon but
seriously I I know we say it a lot and
saying things a lot can sometimes make
them seem trait but we really really
really do appreciate you especially for
me like I haven't gotten to do one these
streams in a while this has been so much
fun thank you all for just your time for
your thoughts and and yes for your
contributions CU they do help out a ton
kindest stream to date kindest stream to
date I know it's fun to watch me rant
but know that it affects me after and my
blood pressure thanks you like I needed
this good one so I can do these again
because after the last one I was like
maybe no more live streams this was
amazing I appreciate you restored Coy's
Faith So yeah thank you guys and a
special special thank you and shout out
to Chris Wham off for again multiple
weeks being so generous to us and and
you in ways that you know people don't
even see behind the scenes and whatnot
uh really super super we're I'm humbled
when I see something like uh cuz yeah I
mean you know we're just here in the
room and it feels like we're just
chatting and stuff like that but it
really means a lot to uh yeah to have
you guys support in whatever form it
comes in so yeah Chris thank you in
particular thank all of you guys hit
that like on your way out get people to
see it and they'll come join the channel
then we can more of these absolutely
send some love to Barnes and uh and
we'll catch you on the next one hope we
got everybody's thoughts and and
inquiries in and if you got anything
left over bring it next time and we'll
talk about it we'll see you soon much
love and a Happy Thanksgiving be well
people cheers